Hallo, guten Abend, mein Name ist Markus Richter. Das ist das Chaos Radio 251 live aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin in der Marienstraße 11, in der das Live im Netz hat. Könnt ihr jetzt noch vorbeikommen und mitmachen, Fragen stellen oder einfach nur zuhören. Wir sprechen heute, wie ich gerade schon angekündigt habe, über Hass im Netz und wenn man sich jetzt fragt, aber Moment mal, wer Hass denn eigentlich gerade wen? Also mal abgesehen vom Grundhass, der ja heutzutage kann man politisch zumindest postulierend irgendwie immer da ist, gibt es keinen aktuellen Anlass, was aber gerade in dieser Diskussion vielleicht von Vorteil ist, weil man dann nicht nur darüber reden kann, wer gerade wen, was und wie Hass, sondern auch wie man die gesellschaftliche Debatte stärken kann, ohne in die Meinungsfreiheit einzugreifen. Weil das ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert, das ist gar nicht so einfach zu führen. Und darüber wollen wir heute Abend sprechen, unter anderem mit Julia Krüger, freie Autorin unter anderem bei netzpolitik.org und wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin von Saskia Esken im Bundestag. Hallo, guten Abend.
Ja, schönen guten Abend.
Außerdem Luca Hammer. Ich habe vergessen mir im Vorfeld noch mal genau zu merken, wo, von wo eigentlich. Also aus dem Internet raus auf jeden Fall. Was ist der Ort? Mitten in NRW. Luca Hammer ist Social Media Analyst. Aber man kann es vielleicht besser so erklären. Falls in den letzten zwei Jahren einen Artikel gelesen habt, wo es irgendwie um soziale Netzwerke, Filterbubble, wer hängt mit wem rum, hängen Dinge zusammen, gibt es Spotnetzwerke, ja oder nein. Und da waren so Grafiken drin. Da sind die konservativ geschätzt 50 Prozent von Luca Hammer. Wahrscheinlich mehr. Außerdem Katharina Nocun, Autoren und Datenreisende. Tag. So, und wir reden heute über Hass. Und ich möchte persönlich anfangen. Meine persönlichen Begegnungen mit Hass im Netz, die, und wir kommen gleich zur Definition, was das eigentlich ist. Und ich würde jetzt erst mal drüber reden wollen. Also was ich als so unangenehm empfunden habe, dass ich denke, das will ich eigentlich nicht haben und das gehört da nicht hin und das tut irgendwie weh. Es gab einmal eine Situation, wo ich irgendwas total, also in meinem Kopf, Belangloses gepostet hatte. Und dann zwei Tage lang mich irgendjemand unfassbar krass belegt hat. Das habe ich aber schon wieder so verdrängt, dass es nicht mehr war. Und dann habe ich mal im Deutschlandfunk Kultur über Gamergate gesprochen. Oh mein Gott. Das waren dann so 15 Accounts, glaube ich. Geschätzt fünf Leute, die dann also auch eine gute Zeit lang sehr laut da gehasst haben. Aber immer so, indem sie belegen und gleichzeitig ganz so ganz kleinteilig Dinge behaupten, die ich gesagt haben könnte, die andere Dinge bedeuten, die man wiederum widerlegen muss. Das war anstrengend, aber interessant. Ich war dann froh, dass es vorbei war. Das sind meine Erlebnisse mit Hass. Also sehr Inselerfahrung, kurze Zeit, kein großes Problem. Aber alle reden ja immer drüber. Julia, wie sieht dein Hass im Netz aus? Oder hattest du Hasserlebnisse?
Also ich muss sagen, ich persönlich habe eigentlich relativ wenig Hass abgekriegt. Aber ich beobachte es doch relativ regelmäßig. Egal, ob es in Bildern ist oder in Ton oder in Text. Also ich erinnere mich sehr gut an irgendwie Jillian York, die sich mal mit Facebook anlegte und dann irgendwelche Bilder von Klopapierrädern und Scheiße bekam. Ich kenne natürlich von Frau Esken viele Trolle, die sozusagen alles krumm nehmen, was man krumm nehmen kann und im Regelfall die konstruktiven Sätze einfach ignorieren. Aber ich glaube, es gibt einen sehr großen Unterschied, ob man so mit einzelnen Leuten zu tun hat, die einfach nur genervt sind und einfach Politiker Scheiße finden. So was passiert mit der Netzpolitik natürlich auch, dass ich irgendwie einen Artikel zum Thema Urheberrecht und Netz-DG schreibe und ganz viele Leute denken, Scheiße, die Arbeit in der Politik, das kann nur schlecht sein, da gehen wir mal gegen an irgendwie. Daher wollte ich eigentlich, ich habe eine komische Doppelrolle, wie du es gerade schon gesagt hast, eigentlich was sagen, wozu ich im Bundestag nicht so richtig komme. Und der Bundestag ist halt auch relativ divers und plötzlich ist alles eins, aber es ist was anderes, als wenn man sozusagen so mit organisierten Hasskampagnen zu tun hat, wozu, glaube ich, Katascha einfach auch noch ein bisschen was sagen kann.
Ja, ich befürchte, ich kann dazu ein bisschen was sagen. Also zunächst einmal, ja, es gibt vielleicht so Gründe oder eher so Begleitumstände, die einen eher wahrscheinlich zu der Zielscheibe von Hass im Netz machen. Und ich muss sagen, meine erste Hassbotschaft, die habe ich interessanterweise gar nicht online bekommen, sondern die kam als Brief bei mir an. Und zwar hatte ich mich erdreistet ein Schimpfwort bei einer politischen Rede damals für die Piraten zu verwenden. Und da hat mir jemand ganz aufgebracht, einen Brief geschrieben, auch in Comic Sans, in dieser geilen Schrift ausgedruckt und an mich adressiert. Und der war dann ziemlich hasserfüllt, muss ich sagen. Und die Details möchte ich euch ersparen. Aber das Ganze waren auch mit Namen unterzeichnet. Es gab eben auch noch so eine gewisse Nicht-Seriosität, vielleicht auch so einen gruseligen Touch. Aber in den Jahren darauf habe ich dann doch sehr viele vielfältige Online-Erfahrungen sammeln dürfen. Gar nicht so sehr als Geschäftsführerin der Piraten, innerhalb der Piraten. Sondern was mir zunächst aufgefallen ist, ist jedes Mal, wenn ein Bericht über mich irgendwo in der Zeitung war, und das war damals ziemlich oft, zum Bundestagswahl 2013 gab es einmal so eine Kommentarspalte. Und ich habe am Anfang den Fehler gemacht, diese Kommentare über mich zu lesen. Und ich muss sagen, 80 Prozent von denen hätte ich mir echt sparen können, weil das waren ausschließlich Kommentare über mein Aussehen. Und das fand ich schon erst mal so befremdlich. Damit habe ich nicht gerechnet. Also ich dachte immer so, als junge Frau in der Politik hört man ja immer, wird ja so gern gesehen. Ja, ein paar Leute haben es.
Das war jetzt das Problem, gesehen, nicht gehört.
Ja, also so, dass ich dann vielleicht auch eine eigene Meinung hatte, kam nicht ganz so gut an. Und ich glaube, so die richtig krassen Hassmails habe ich dann bekommen, als ich mich dann erdreistet habe, in einer Talkshow dann was zur gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung zu sagen. Und zwar war ich der Meinung, dass, ja, es klingt jetzt so lustig, ne, ist es gar nicht. Ich habe einfach nur ganz sachlich gesagt, ich fände es gut, wenn wir eine Bürgerversicherung für alle hätten wollen, auch Beamte einzahlen. Daraufhin habe ich sehr viele E-Mails bekommen von Leuten, auch unterschrieben mit Professor, Doktor, so und so, die richtig krass waren. Also von geh mal arbeiten, du Junge, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, bis hin zu ganz üblichen Beschimpfungen einfach. Und das hat mich dann doch schon schockiert, weil Hass im Netz, man hat ja auch immer da so ein Bild davon, dass halt irgendwie jemand mit einem anonymen Namen einem was schreibt. Nee, bei mir war das halt immer unterzeichnet mit Adresse. Und übrigens, ich habe einen Doktortitel.
Wow, das ist also quasi nochmal ein Trolldiplom.
Genau, ein Trolldiplom. Und später ging es dann richtig los. Da habe ich mich erdreistet, in meinem Blog eine Analyse des Wahlprogramms der AfD zu veröffentlichen. Das war zum Landtagswahlkampf im Baden-Württemberg. Und das ist dann viral gegangen, haben sich dann bestimmt so eine Million Menschen angeguckt. Und daraufhin ging es dann richtig los. Also nicht nur, dass die AfD Baden-Württemberg natürlich über mich einen Blogpost veröffentlicht hat, in dem sie über mich hergezogen sind, sondern daraufhin haben dann Leute gezielt, mir geschrieben, gezielt, mir Drogen zukommen lassen und so weiter und so fort. Und ja, mittlerweile muss ich sagen, bin ich halt recht erprobt, was Hass, Trollerei und bis hin zu übelsten Stalking angeht. Ich muss sagen, ich blende, dass mittlerweile relativ gut aus und das finde ich eigentlich schon das Erschreckendste an dem Ganzen, dass ich mich gar nicht mehr so im Alltag darüber empöre, sondern halt eher so, ach ja, wieder so eine Drohung, ach, blocken.
Also wir können nachher auf jeden Fall definitiv auch noch mal drüber reden, ob das vielleicht auch eine Strategie ist. Also weil du dich im Prinzip schon so eine Art vorentschuldigt, dass du das machst, aber vielleicht ist das ja auch ein Weg, können wir noch mal reden. Luca, hast du auch schon mit Erfahrung machen können selber? Also wir kommen noch dazu über die Analysen, aber persönlich?
Ja, also wenn ich zu bestimmten Themen Sachen veröffentlicht, dann kommt natürlich schon diverse Rückmeldungen. Ich habe mich ja zeitlang mit ein paar Trollgruppen beschäftigt, die natürlich auch sehr viel Spaß haben, mit Beleidigungen um sich zu werfen. Aber wahrscheinlich auch so bis in der privilegierten Position weit weg von Berlin und weit weg von anderen Menschen, die das Internet verwenden, dadurch, dass sie halt schon von vornherein eine gewisse Distanz haben und auch sonst wenig angreifbar, wenn man nicht angestellt ist, wenn niemand zum Arbeitgeber gehen kann. Und so ist es wesentlich einfacher, mit diesen ganzen Sachen umzugehen.
Nachdem wir einmal die Runde gemacht haben, würde ich die zurückgehen wollen mit der Frage, was ist denn jetzt Hass im Netz oder Hatespeed? Was ist denn Hatespeed? Luca, wie würdest du Hatespeed definieren? Gibt es das überhaupt? Weil ich habe das Gefühl, dass das, weil diese Diskussion geht ja schon eine Weile, dass das mittlerweile ein Wort ist, wo alle, wenn man das sagt so, wissen, nicken, ja ja, Hatespeed. Aber keiner mehr so ganz genau weiß, was man eigentlich damit meint. So dass es so einen diffusen Konsens gibt, aber vielleicht gar keine Definition mehr. Gibt es die?
Für mich verwende ich es einfach ganz einfach, dass ich sage, es ist mehr als nur eine Abneigung, sondern es geht schon dahin, dass man der Person schaden möchte. Und es gibt sehr viele unterschiedliche Wege, wie man einer Person schadet. Das kann jetzt rein emotional sein, also dass man über Beleidigungen, man versucht den bunten Punkt der Person zu finden, sei das jetzt, dass man Personen in ihrem Umfeld angreift, dass man sie übers Aussehen kritisiert, dass man sie über Dinge kritisiert, die man halt nicht ändern kann, über Geschlecht, Hautfarbe, was auch immer. Es kann aber auch dahin gehen, dass man versucht, so einen Puck aufzubauen, damit die Person sich halt nicht mehr äußert in Zukunft.
Würdet ihr das unterschreiben, anders definieren, ehrlich sehen?
Na, ich hab mich mal irgendwann damit ein bisschen wissenschaftlich beschäftigt. Und ich glaube, es gibt eine ganz, ganz starke Verschiebung. Früher war das, was man ganz einfach als Hate Speech benutzt, hier einfach Volksverhetzung. Ich glaube, dieser Diskurs kommt ganz stark aus Amerika, Hate Speech. Und eigentlich meint das sozusagen, alle Inhalte, die Menschen tatsächlich, wie Luca gerade schon gesagt hat, wegen Herkunft, Hautfarbe, Geschlecht, sexuelle Orientierung, der körperlichen Einschränkung oder der Religion angreifen oder auch so was verherrlichen oder fördern. Das ist teils in Deutschland strafbar, international ist das relativ unterschiedlich. Volksverhetzung ist hier strafbar, Aufrufe zu Gewalt sind strafbar, Beleidigung ist strafbar unter Umständen. Teilweise ist das natürlich nicht strafbar. Also es gibt, glaube ich, sehr unterschiedliche Formen. Ich fand ja die Beispiele von den Professoren auch gerade unglaublich toll. Genau. Ich fand es ganz interessant, dass mit dem Netz, der hier eigentlich so ein Versuch gemacht wurde, also mit dem Netzwerk Durchsetzung, sozusagen das zu definieren, was heißt das eigentlich, aber absurderweise sind da halt knapp 20 Straftatbestände drinnen gelandet, bis hin zur Landesverhetzung, was das Ganze wieder völlig ungreifbar macht. Genau, aber das ist glaube ich so ein erster Orientierungspunkt, was das eigentlich strafgesetztechnisch heißt.
Ja, also ich würde auch sagen, dass Hate Speech auch so ein bisschen, also klar kann man eine allgemeine Definition versuchen, und das ist auch extrem wichtig, vor allem wenn man dann halt irgendwie guckt, wenn man beispielsweise Richtlinien, Vorschriften, Gesetze oder sogar machen will, wie das eindämmen sollen, aber ich muss sagen, so für mich als Betroffene habe ich da auch einen ganz individuellen Blick drauf. Also jeder hat ja einen anderen wunden Punkt, sage ich mal. Und bei mir als Frau ist es ganz oft so, also ich kriege in den letzten Monaten hat das sehr stark zugenommen, ja so Bedrohung in der Hinsicht, dass einem gewünscht wird, dass man irgendwie Teil einer Gruppenvergewaltigung wird. Also so ganz gezielt dieser Aspekt, du bist eine Frau, also es ist richtig ekelhaft, aber sowas kriegt man dann. Wenn man über rechte Netzwerke schreibt, dann Aussehen finde ich ist viel stärker bei Frauen als bei Männern, weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass gerade man da halt versucht, jemanden auch nochmal so sehr stark abzuwerten, was anscheinend bei Frauen vielleicht einfacher ist, über das Aussehen zu machen als anders. Und da ist auch noch das Statement so, ich setze mich nicht mal inhaltlich mit dir auseinander. Du siehst so doof aus, dass ich das gar nicht brauche. Und das ist ja auch so sehr abwertend. Eine andere Sache ist aber auch eine ganz klare Androhung zur Gewalt. Und das macht natürlich etwas mit allem. Ich habe einmal in einer Zeit, wo ich eine Kampagne gegen das Sterben im Mittelmeer zur Rettung von Menschen dort geleitet habe, habe ich sehr viele Hassposts bekommen. Und da war eins dabei. Das haben wir sogar zum Anwalt gegeben damals mit meinem Arbeitgeber gemeinsam. Da hat jemand gesagt, wir lauern dir nachts auf mit meinen Kameraden so aus dem richtigen Umfeld. Und wir kümmern uns dann um dich. Das Interessante ist, dass man schon etwas mit einem macht. Ich würde nicht sagen, man muss die starke Person sein, wenn man sowas kriegt und sich nicht runterkriegen lassen. Natürlich mache ich das nicht, aber es macht schon etwas mit einem. Von daher finde ich das auch noch mal ganz wichtig, zu betonen, wie wichtig das ist, Leuten beizustehen, die so eine Erfahrung zu machen. Jeden ernst zu nehmen, der sagt, das hat diese Wirkung auf mich. Auch wenn man selbst vielleicht sagt, so ein Kommentar blendet das doch einfach aus, ignoriere das.
Willst du den Strategien noch ausführlicher kommen? Und würde noch mal bei dem Begriff stehen bleiben wollen?
Das Ziel ist schon, jemanden mundtot zu machen. Also finde ich schon, egal mit welchen Mitteln, so jemanden anzugehen, dass er sich wahrscheinlich nicht noch mal traut, sich in so einer Situation zu äußern.
Ist das wirklich das Ziel oder ist das eines der Ziele? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn so was passiert, dann ist eines der möglichen Ziele, dass man jemanden aus dem Verkehr zieht, jemanden mundtot machen, einen politischen Gegner vielleicht. Aber ist das das Einzige oder besteht zumindest die Vermutung, dass manche Leute das einfach aus Spaß an der Erniedrigung machen?
Das auch.
Ohne Ziel.
Ja, es gibt bestimmt unterschiedliche Motivationen. Im politischen Kontext ist natürlich das mundtot machen, was ich am stärksten wahrnehme. Ich hatte allerdings auch Erfahrungen mit Leuten, die eher im Bereich Stalking unterwegs sind. Da war das auch in dem Moment, wo man ganz klar gesagt hat, ich möchte mit dir nichts zu tun haben, da war es schon so ein verletzender Charakter. Ich möchte jemandem wehtun oder jemandem Angst einjagen, weil er mich ablehnt.
Da würde ich noch kurz einlaufen am Erich Fromm. Er unterscheidet zwischen reaktivem und charakterbedingtem Hass. Reaktive ist das, was aus der Situation heraus passiert. Wenn man zum Beispiel eingegriffen wird, das muss nicht mal ein Angriff sein, aber kann eine Meldung sein, mit der man nicht einverstanden ist. Dann sagt man sofort, es stimmt ja nicht, du bist doof, oder was auch immer. Und das andere, der charakterbedingte Hass, der das Ganze schon fast internalisiert hat. Dass man ständig in diesem Hass, man hat dieses Feindbild, das man überall sieht. Und das gibt dann vielleicht auch ein gewisses Machtgefühl, dass man gegen diese Personen und Personengruppe ständig ankämpft.
Was ich mal ganz interessant fand, war ein Beitrag von Agnes Calamard. Die hat sich Hate Speech im internationalen Kontext angeguckt und sehr viele Genozide auseinandergenommen. Und die meinte, dass es grundsätzlich zum Mundhutmachen benutzt wird, zur Einschüchterung von Leuten, ganz klar auch zum Rekrutieren von Gleichgesinnten, von Sympathisanten. Also wir sind hier, ihr könnt euch auch anschließen. Dann hat es natürlich eine ganz, ganz, ganz starke Funktion vom Agenda Setting, also dass soweit man sozusagen auch bislang nicht Mainstream, also schwierige Sachen sagen kann, das wird mehr werden, die halt auch Mainstream so. Ich glaube, dass es einen großen Unterschied macht, ob man mit Leuten zu tun hat, die das wirklich strategisch zu politischen Zwecken einsetzen oder ob man mit Leuten zu tun hat, die das tatsächlich sozusagen nachahmen, weil es gerade common sense wird.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Also wir haben jetzt, was bis jetzt so anklang, ist dann das Hate Speech immer eine bewusste Aktion. Also mit einem Ziel oder zumindest mit einer kleinen Motivation. Ich habe mich gerade gefragt, gibt es dann auch, also jetzt vielleicht plump gesagt, Mitläuferinnen, die einfach sozusagen mit am Start sind, vielleicht selber gar nicht mitkriegen, dass das, was sie machen, auf der Gegenseite unfassbar krasse Effekte haben kann?
Grundsätzlich muss man sagen, dass es international echt keine richtigen Studien gibt. Es gibt sozusagen so Theorien dazu. Es ist glaube ich klar, dass es irgendwie Sinn machen würde, sich mal anzugucken, woher kommt denn das, wohin geht denn das, wer verstärkt denn das eigentlich, erreicht das eigentlich die Ziele oder nicht und so. Es würde sehr viel Sinn machen, Studien zu machen, aber es ist gerade in sozialen Netzwerken unglaublich schwierig. Meine eigene Erfahrung ist, dass das nachahm zunimmt. Damit bekomme ich auch mehr Kontakt. Mit denen kann man aber reden, zumindest auf Netzpolitik kann man mit denen reden.
Also die nehmen den Tonfall einfach an, weil man es schon woanders gesehen hat, aber wenn man sie dann darauf aufmerksam macht und das wegbricht, dann geht das auch.
Wenn man sich tatsächlich auf eine gute Diskussion mit ihnen einlässt, dann kann man das ausdiskutieren. Hingegen, glaube ich, Leute, die es wirklich nur auf Hass oder nur auf Ärger absehen, da kriegt man das, glaube ich, nicht hin. Was ich zum Beispiel auch gerade ganz interessant finde, nicht bloß bei öffentlichen Diskussionen, sondern vor allem auch bei Chats, ist nicht nur was die Leute schreiben, sondern diese ganzen Kommas und Punkte und so. Also das immer mehr, sobald man mit jemandem im Chat in Konflikt gerät, ich plötzlich zehn Fragezeichen bekomme von Leuten, die bisher relativ ordentlich schreiben konnten.
Hattest du jetzt Harry Prattet mal gesagt, mehr als drei Ausrufezeichen sind ein sicheres Zeichen von Wahnsinn?
Also das finde ich halt wirklich seltsam, weil das suggeriert halt immer gleich so ein extremes Level an Abwehr, obwohl eigentlich meistens nur ein kleines Missverständnis bestand, weil man sich nicht gesehen hat, während man was gesagt hat, sondern halt die verbale Sprache halt extrem reduziert ist so, ne? Da können sehr schnell Missverständnisse auftauchen.
Ich will mal noch zu diesem Begriff Hate Speech was fragen. Ich hab neulich auf einem Podium gesessen mit Tarek Tesfu, das ist ein YouTuber, der also Hate in Lastwagenlieferungen bekommt. Und der sagt, er findet den Begriff Hate Speech eigentlich fehlleitend, weil der im reinen Online-Kontext benutzt wirkt. Und das ist für ihn falsch, dass man so tut, das ist ein Online-Phänomen, weil das einfach nur eine weitere Ausprägung von Rassismus, Sexismus, Ableismus, was auch immer ist, was es gibt. Und ich kann das als Argumentation nachvollziehen, frage mich aber einer. Aber andererseits ist das wirklich so? Also ist das wirklich genau dasselbe oder hat das Online schon eine andere Qualität?
Also ich würde sagen, dass das Online durch so eine Bühnenfunktion noch einmal anders ist. Während offline Hass halt sehr oft so im direkten Gespräch ist, hat man es online halt sehr oft, dass der Hass vor einer Bühne ist, vor den eigenen Followern, um eben zu zeigen, ach, ich bin so super und ich mache jetzt die Leute fertig. Und man macht es plötzlich auch gemeinsam. Während schon, ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen, dass das offline alles nur eine Person ist. Da gibt es auch immer wieder, dass sich Gruppen zusammentun. Aber online ist das halt wesentlich schneller. Da fängt einer anderen ein bisschen zu stichern, versucht eine Person herauszufordern, dass sie halt irgendwas schreibt, darauf reagiert. Und dann kommen gleich noch zehn weitere Accounts dazu, die dann auch auf der Person auf herum hängen.
Und meinst du, dass das auch anstachelt im Sinne von, weil mir potenziell hier viele zugucken, lehne ich mich noch weiter aus dem Fenster?
Also wir sprechen ja, glaube ich, über unglaublich viele Medien, so, ne? Also Blogs, irgendwie dann sozusagen soziale Netzwerke, dann YouTube und Facebook, das ist, glaube ich, ein riesen Unterschied. Twitter auch noch, einfach was die Öffentlichkeit angeht.
Hätte ich jetzt natürlich gar nicht gedacht. Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, man kann das zumindest im Rahmen dieser Diskussionen unter diesem schönen Sammelbegriff soziale Netzwerke zusammenfassen. Also im Sinne alles, was eine Social-Funktion hat.
Also...
Da gibt es wahrscheinlich andere Abgründe und das Moor hat vielleicht Grün- oder Popelgelb. Aber im Prinzip, würde ich... Hätte ich jetzt vermutet, die Mechanismen sind dieselbe.
Also das Problem ist, dass Twitter am meisten untersucht ist. Gegen bei YouTube, dass immer große Einser-Stories sind. Und bei Facebook vieles noch intransparenter verläuft, weil das sozusagen nicht so offen einsehbar ist. Insgesamt fand ich einen Beitrag von einem Wissenschaftler wieder ganz interessant. Er meinte, dass gerade bei Facebook halt das Problem ist, dass dadurch, dass man insgesamt tatsächlich mit eher geschlossenen Gruppen zu tun hat, mit größeren Echo, kann man insgesamt der Diskurs in eine Richtung laufen kann. Dass sozusagen die Leute, die da drin sind, peu à peu durch die Vielzahl der immer mehr bekannten Kommentare und Inhalte, dass sich da sozusagen das Bild verschiebt, was die Leute von dem Meinungsklima in der Gruppe haben. Und dass sich dadurch z.B. die lauten Minderheiten ganz schnell in der Mehrheit wehnen. Einfach weil keiner mehr widerspricht. Und sozusagen aus Angst auch immer weniger Peu à peu widersprechen. Und dadurch sozusagen sich die Hassredenden, die fühlen sich einfach auch sehr stark, die fühlen sich gut informiert, es kommt wenig anderes rein. Und dadurch verstärkt sich das immer mehr. Das fand ich eine ganz interessante Erklärung, warum das online schon ein anderes Thema ist als offline. Auch wenn es theoretisch natürlich jede Klasse, wenn eine ganze Klasse einen Schüler mobbt, theoretisch ist das dasselbe Muster beim Gruppenmobbing. Da kann es halt nur viel größer sein.
Also da fällt mir bei den Facebook-Gruppen ein ganz interessantes Beispiel ein. Und zwar habe ich letztens das Buch von Franziska Schreiber Inside AfD gelesen, die war ja mal Mitglied in der AfD. Die war sogar Landesvorsitzende der jungen AfD in Sachsen. Und sie hat da auch sehr intensiv beschrieben, wie ihre Sozialisation in die Partei war. Anfangs ist sie wegen Luka eingetreten. Meinte, sie wäre damals auch nicht rechts gewesen. Und dann fand eigentlich auch die komplette Kommunikation der Jugend innerhalb von Facebook-Gruppen.
Ich muss kurz einer wegen Luka, nicht wegen dem, der jetzt bei uns in der Werbung ist.
Wegen dem gründer der AfD. Genau, nicht wegen dem Social-Media-Experten, nein. Auf jeden Fall hat sie beschrieben, dort gab es eine Gruppe, in der alle Leute, die eher zum rechten Lager gehörten, waren. Und die hieß der Garten. Nach dem Spruch, die Harten kommen in den Garten. Dort haben sich die Leute vom Rechtsaußenflügel gegenseitig bestärkt. Sie hat am Ende des Buches sehr gut beschrieben, dass sie nach ihrem Austritt, wo sie aus diesen ganzen Gruppen rausgegangen ist, wo sie nicht mehr in ihr normales Facebook-Konto mit ihrer Filterblase sich eingeloggt hat, plötzlich festgestellt, die Welt ist eine ganz andere, als das, was sich immer als Bestärkung bekommen hat. Sie meinte, da gab es eben auch diese Gruppendynamik. Wenn jemand mal etwas kritisiert hat oder gesagt hat, naja, das ist jetzt wohl doch ein bisschen zu weit gegangen, der neueste Holocaust-Vergleich oder sowas, dann wurden die sofort öffentlich fertig gemacht. Und dieses öffentlich fertig machen hat ja auch so eine Gruppenfunktion, sag ich mal.
Also öffentlich in dieser Gruppe?
Öffentlich in dieser Gruppe. Also quasi halb öffentlich, kann man schon sagen. Aber das hat dann natürlich auch wieder, man bringt die Leute auf Linie.
Vielleicht einfach nur ergänzend. So eine Gehirnstruktur, so ein Selbstbild, bildet sich ähnlich aus wie das Netz. Es ist sehr viel abhängig davon, wie stark und wie oft Neuronen im Kopf gereizt werden. Wenn immer nur derselbe Reiz eingeht, dann bildet sich einfach ein unglaublich stabiles Weltbild aus, was aber komplett falsch sein kann.
Ja, und wenn mein Umfeld um mich rum immer eine bestimmte Sprache spricht. Ich merk das immer, wenn ich in Ruhrpott fahre, dann komm ich immer mit ganz viel Wat und Dat zurück. Das ist natürlich schön, aber dann brauch ich immer so ein paar Tage, um mich zu resozialisieren. Und genauso ist es halt, wenn ich mit Leuten rumhänge, die sich gewohnheitsmäßig mit Schimpfwörtern überziehen. Die meinen das vielleicht gar nicht so. Nehm ich das auch an. Und wenn die das aber schon so meinen und gezielt ihre Gruppenidentität darüber formen, dass sie immer gegen andere Gruppen herziehen, dann übernimmt man das natürlich auch, wenn man dann nicht sensibel genug ist oder vielleicht in solchen Kreisen einfach auch reinwächst.
Lieber Ropott, das war nur eine Analogie, um einen Mechanismus zu erzählen. Das ist uns sehr wichtig. Wir machen an dieser Stelle eine kurze Pause, hören eine Musik von Lee Roseware vom Album Since Chronicity Neon Skies und reden dann gleich mal drüber, nachdem wir jetzt über das was geredet haben, über das wer und wie viele eigentlich. Chaosradio 251 über Hass im Netz. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, was das ist am konkreten Beispiel und wie man das vielleicht definieren kann. Und wollen jetzt mal ein bisschen über die, naja, über das Wie und das Wer versuchen zu sprechen. Ich will mal platt anfangen. Und Luca, der sich ja damit beschäftigt, Netzwerk zu analysieren, fragen, ist jeder Hate-Poster ein anderer, eigener, originärer Mensch? Oder besteht das Internet aus künstlichen Social-Bot-Troll-Armeen?
Also bei den Social-Bots, da bin ich sehr kritisch. Also wie Michael Kray, bin ich seit Jahren auf der Suche nach diesen Social-Bots.
Bevor du sagst, dass es die vielleicht nicht gibt, können wir es wie bei Hate Switch machen. Du erklärst noch mal kurz, was das sein soll.
Also Social-Bots sollen Computer-Programme sein, die sich als Menschen ausgeben und für Menschen eigentlich nicht direkt unterscheidbar sind. Also angeblich Programme, die in Touring-Test bestehen würden. Deshalb ist es wahrscheinlich so schwer, sie zu finden.
Also Touring-Test ist dieses Ding, wo eben genau ein Mensch mit einem Roboter spricht und dann nicht mehr sagen kann, war das jetzt ein Roboter oder ein Mensch? Und du zweifelst aber daran, obwohl viele Menschen daran glauben oder glauben wollen, zweifelst du daran, dass es die gibt.
Warum? Weil ich sie noch nicht gefunden habe. Also entweder sind tatsächlich Social Pots, die die perfekte Menschen, also die perfekte Simulation sind, die ich nicht davon unterscheiden kann. Aber bisher war es immer so, wenn der Verdacht da war, dass man sich dann die Accounts angeschaut hat. Und oft war es halt einfach plumpe Automatisierung, also einfach die halt einfach auf bestimmte Begriffe reagiert haben, wo man dann Muster erkennt, dass dann die Frage ob man das jetzt noch als Social Pots bezeichnet oder eben nicht. Und ansonsten haben sie es halt oft als Menschen herausgestellt. Ich glaube, es war auch im ZDF oder irgendwo mal Reportage, wo sie halt den Nachgangen sind. Und dann haben sie halt so einen Account gefunden, der hat halt am Tag mehrere hundert Tweets oder Facebook-Posts, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, veröffentlicht. Und Wissenschaftler haben gemeint, ja, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Social Pots. Und dann haben sie da hinterher recherchiert und sind halt draufgekommen, es war halt ein Pensionist, der den ganzen Tag vom Computer gesessen ist und halt diese Postings veröffentlicht hat. Und da glaube ich, ja, da glaube ich, dass halt eigentlich das größere Problem tatsächlich Menschen sind. Also Menschen, die da sehr viel Zeit investieren, was ich schon glaube, ist oder was wir inzwischen wissen, ist, dass bestimmte Personen auch mehrere Accounts betreiben. Also das wird das Sockenbuppen dann bezeichnet, mit denen sie halt dann miteinander sprechen. Das gibt es auf jeden Fall. Aber die sind dann halt nicht mehr wirklich zu unterscheiden von außen, weil es halt tatsächlich Menschen sind, die darüber kommunizieren, aber die halt nicht die Person sind, für die sie sich ausgeben.
Aber nochmal, also jetzt keine Socialbots, aber sowas wie Automatisierung gibt es schon. Das stelle ich mir jetzt irgendwie in zwei Geschmacksrichtungen vor. Das eine ist, ich programmiere sozusagen einen Twitter-Account, der auf bestimmte Hashtags dann irgendwie Schimpft drauf wirft, keine Ahnung, Refugees welcome. Wer das als Hashtag twittert, wird irgendwie beschimpft. Und das andere ist, der folgt bestimmten Accounts und retweetet die einfach, damit die mehr Sichtbarkeit im Netz haben. Gibt es sowas?
Also Retweetbots sind ganz oft, die waren auch bei der Bundestagswahl letztes Jahr dabei, die halt einfach bestimmte Accounts oder bestimmte Themen weiterverbreitet haben. Aber der Effekt war halt sehr gering. Also es ist so ein gutes Gefühl vielleicht für die Leute, die den Tweet veröffentlichen und Sekunden danach werden sie getweetet und gefafft. Aber diese Retweetbots, die haben keine echten Follower. Also die erreichen dadurch jetzt nicht mehr Menschen. Natürlich ist es wieder ein anderes Ding, das Twitter, das dann irgendwie mit dem Algorithmus höher rankt und dann mehr Followern anzeigt. Also je nachdem, wo man den neuen Algorithmus losen oder den alten Feed verwendet. Und da gibt es sicherlich Effekte. Auf anderen Plattformen ist das möglicherweise stärker. Aber wie schon gesagt worden ist, dort ist es auch schwieriger zu untersuchen. Bei WhatsApp, bei Facebook kommt man fast nicht rein.
Letzte Frage an dich. Gibt es bestimmte, wie soll ich das sagen, Denkrichtungen, politische Einstellungen, die besonders gerne diese Technologien oder bzw. diesen Hass in Masse benutzen oder an den Start bringen?
Also was ich in Deutschland so beobachtet habe, gibt es so eine Gruppe von 10.000 bis 15.000 Accounts rund um die AfD, die sehr gern bei gewissen Shitstorms mitmachen und dann in der Masse auf Einzelaccounts herumhacken.
Wie ist eure Erfahrung hier in Berlin?
Also darf ich anfangen? Erstmal muss ich ja sagen, es gibt ja auch unglaublich coole Bots. Also ich hatte mal Kontakt mit dem Marte-Bot, den mag ich sehr.
Mit dem wen?
Mit dem Marte-Bot.
Marte-Bot?
Ja, es gibt auch einen Happy-Bot.
Okay.
Es gibt natürlich auch Omas-Bot, also wenn man sich den Spaß machen mag.
Aber das sind ja Bots, die spielen ja damit.
Genau.
Dass sie sagen, hey, ich bin ein Bot, kommunizier mit mir, dann wird es irgendwie lustig, oder?
Genau, aber gerade Omas-Bot ist glaube ich tatsächlich auch gebaut, um sozusagen mal so ein bisschen, ein bisschen Fundament in den deutschen Diskurs dazu zu bringen für Normalbürger und auch zu gucken, was geht denn damit und was nicht. Eigentlich kommt halt auch dieser Diskurs extrem krass aus den USA und hängt natürlich ganz stark zusammen mit der Wahl von Donald Trump und in den USA war die Lage tatsächlich ein bisschen anders. Also da gibt es eine ganz tolle Studie von Ethan Sagermann von Bergmann Klein Center in Harvard. Die haben tatsächlich mal so das ganze, also die ganzen Twitter-Accounts auseinandergenommen und hatten halt irgendwie festgestellt, dass es eine bestimmte Gruppe von sozusagen hochparteiischen Inhalten doch sozusagen durch Bots irgendwie zu 40 Prozent oder so gestreut wurde und hatten halt gesehen, dass, glaube ich, gerade im Kontext von Trump nicht nur das mit Likes und Shares einherging, sondern auch zum Teil auch mit sehr schnellen Antworten auf irgendwelche Kommentare, aber das konnte man halt für Deutschland überhaupt nicht so bestätigen. Es kann sein, dass da einfach die Technologie ausgereift ist, kann sein, dass sie fürs Englischsprachige ausgereift ist. Für Deutschland sagen alle Studien, das ist so nicht nachweisbar, wobei die Studien auch manchmal komisch sind, wenn die bloß die Anzahl von Tweets pro Tag messen oder so. Also gut, also kann man natürlich auch viel programmieren, aber für Deutschland lässt sich das auf jeden Fall so nicht nachweisen. Hier ist eher das Problem mit Fake-Accounts oder mit so inoffiziell agierenden Partei-Accounts, die sehr groß werden können, oder wo dann die Follower gefaked sind oder irgendwas.
Aber das heißt, man kann das eigentlich noch gar nicht untersuchen? Oder ist es so, dass es noch nicht genau untersucht wird, weil wenn man an der Oberfläche kratzt, kriegt man schon eine geile Schlagzeile als Untersucher?
Na, das auf jeden Fall. Also das Oxford Internet Institute ist damit groß geworden. Also dass man eine große Schlagzeile kriegt, wenn man es nachweist. Der Nachweis ist halt relativ schwierig. Also man braucht halt irgendwelche Indikatoren. Man kann sozusagen sagen, okay, 40 Tweets pro Tag sind ein Indikator. So viel Twitter hat kein Mensch. Ich kenne da einige Leute, die sozusagen so viel twittern. Man könnte sagen, man kann natürlich gucken, ob es gewisse Regelmäßigkeiten gibt. Aber ich meine, jeder gute Programmierer wird sich zu helfen wissen, die Bot-Aktivitäten unregelmäßig zu programmieren. Ich glaube, Michael Krall hat dazu mal einen ganz interessanten Talk gemacht, was alles versucht wurde, um das eindeutig zu identifizieren. Da ist unglaublich viel unklar. Es gibt ja auch immer Politiker, die Angst haben, ihnen folgten so viele Eierkopfe. Das mussten alles Bots sein oder so. Oder es mussten alles irgendwelche Fake-Accounts sein. Da sollte sich irgendwie bei näherem Hingucken raus, dass alle Leute sich neu bei Twitter anmelden. Die kriegen als erstes so Empfehlungen, wem sie folgen. Die haben natürlich noch kein Profil und klicken erst mal aus Unkenntnis auf Ja. Und schon hat irgendwie Frau Esken oder Frau Künast unglaublich viele Follower. Weiß nicht woher, aber das sind einfach nur Neunutzer, die noch nichts eingestellt haben. Also nicht jeder Eierkopf ist irgendwie suspekt. Und da gibt es halt ganz viele methodische Probleme. Es gibt einfach keine saubere Methode automatisiert, also Accounts zu erkennen.
Also fake von echten...
Ja, also es gibt einfach...
Wie...
Ich will fragen, wer hasst im Netz? Wir haben jetzt AfD gehört, das ist natürlich sozusagen ein wohlfeiles Beispiel, aber sind das die einzigen? Oder passt das dann auch so gut ins Bild?
Ja, so hat es ja Gamergate noch so als Beispiel genannt. Also meine Erfahrung ist auch, sobald ich irgendwas feministisches poste, kann das vielleicht so 3, 2, 1, dann kommt der große Einschlag. Und dann habe ich den ganzen Tag Spaß mit vielen interessanten Nachrichten und ab und zu mal ein Penisbild. Ja, das ist halt, also es gibt halt schon bestimmte Themen, wo ich das Gefühl habe, da sind Leute aus irgendeinem mir nicht bekannten Grund so unglaublich, haben so eine unglaubliche Grundfrustration. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was ich denen getan haben soll. Und das lassen die dann halt alles so raus. Also viele Themen, glaube ich. Also, ich meine, jeder, der im Bereich Software unterwegs ist. Und es gab letztens halt auch mal größere Diskussionen über Hass auf Mailing-Wisten in so diversen freien Software-Projekten. Also, ich glaube, dass Leute so Hass auskippen, das ist nicht nur auf Social Networks beschränkt. Und das ist auch nicht auf, sag ich mal, rechte Projekte, die sich gegen linke Projekte richten, beschränkt. Aber ich finde, das sind so, sag ich mal, die Dinge, die momentan auch den größten politischen Impact haben. Also, wir beobachten ja in den USA, aber auch in vielen westlichen Ländern, auch nicht nur in Deutschland, bestimmte Gruppen, die sich sammeln und nicht mehr oder weniger als einen konservativen Backlash fordern. Also sowohl was Frauenrechte angeht, als auch was grundlegende Dinge, an die wir uns in der Demokratie gewöhnt haben, angeht. Auch Pressefreiheit und so weiter. Und das wird momentan von politischen Gruppen da sehr stark gepusht. Und ich glaube, die Grundproblematik, die sich bei Social Bots stellt, ist ja nicht, ist es ein Bot oder ist es nicht ein Bot. Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt egal. Mir macht es mindestens genauso viel Sorge, wenn irgendeine Partei oder irgendeine Gruppe das organisiert, dass da 20 Leute den ganzen Tag auf einer Couch sitzen, vielleicht jeder 10 Fake-Accounts an der Hand haben und die den ganzen Tag befüllen. Das ist ja zehnmal effektiver als ein Bot.
Das ist der Punkt, wo wir jetzt über die angebliche russische Trollfabrik sprechen können.
Na ja, aber es gab ja schon ein Beispiel in Deutschland. Das hatte der Kollege Michael Kreil, der auch bei Netzpolitik dazu einen Beitrag veröffentlicht hat. Mal recherchiert, da gab es einen sehr großen Twitter-Account. Ballerina nannte er sich, angeblich eine junge Balletttänzerin, wie es halt so ist. Die hat dann sehr viel zum Thema AfD gepostet. Die haben da mal so ein bisschen nachrecherchiert. Ja, stellte sich halt raus, war ein älterer Mann aus Münster. War halt keine Ballerina. Solche Dinge finde ich mindestens genauso empörend wert, als wenn man sich über eine Bot-Armee unterhält. Nachdem dieser Beitrag veröffentlicht wurde, hat sich auch der Account verändert. Plötzlich war es dann ein offizieller AfD-Account. Also nicht etwa nur von einem Unterstützer, sondern wirklich von Personen, die für eine Partei arbeiten. Da geht es ja auch um politische Transparenz. Es macht einen Unterschied, ob das jetzt eine 18-jährige Balletttänzerin aus Münster schreibt oder jemand, der für die AfD bezahlt arbeitet.
Da würde ich nachher gerne noch mal drüber reden. Also sagen, inwieweit man heutzutage noch davon ausgehen kann, dass man sowas immer für bare Münze nehmen muss. Ich würde aber gerne bei diesen Massenorganisationen von Hass im Netz bleiben und eben diese...
Twitter hat vor ein paar Wochen 9 Millionen Feats von der Internet Research Agency, also von dieser russischen Organisation veröffentlicht, die...
Ich muss beim Chaosradio immer noch mal diesen einen Schritt zurück machen. Also bei diesen ganzen politischen Hass- slash Rechtspopulismus-Diskussionen gibt es immer wieder die These, die mehr oder weniger auch begründet wurde, dass es also in Russland oder von Russland finanziert diese, wie heißt die Internet Agency?
Research Agency.
Internet Research Agency gibt also ein Unternehmen, das nur dafür da ist, dass da Leute vor Bildschirmen sitzen und Dinge in soziale Netzwerke einkippen, die dann wiederum zu so einer Extremisierung letztendlich führen. So, jetzt Luca bitte noch mal.
Also Twitter hat den neun Millionen Geets von Accounts, die sie dieser ERA zugeordnet haben, veröffentlicht. Und ich hab mir die halt angeschaut und in diesen neun Millionen Geets sind eben auch 100.000 Deutschsprache. Also genau sind es 99.332. Und der Großteil von diesen Deutschsprachen Geets sind halt einfach Nachrichtenmeldungen. Ich hab da jetzt nicht wirklich Muster erkannt. Die haben Bild, dass Süddeutsche alle möglichen Nachrichtenportale eben veröffentlicht. Und ich geh davon aus, dass die einfach die aktuellen Meldungen veröffentlicht haben, damit der Account halt ausschaut, das wär es irgendjemand, der sich für Nachrichten interessiert. Aber wenn man diese ganzen Links rausfiltert, dann bleiben noch irgendwie so 10.000 Tweets. Und die sind auf so neun Tage verteilt. Und an jedem von diesen Tagen haben mehrere von diesen Internet Research Agency Accounts zu bestimmten Themen was veröffentlicht. Ich kann noch nicht wirklich, ich versteh nicht genau, was das Ziel davon war, aber es hat halt immer irgendwie so ein Überthema gegeben. Die meisten sehr banal, das Einzige, was halt rausgesprochen ist, ist am Tag der Bundestagswahl, sind halt pro AfD-Tweets gekommen. Die anderen waren so was wie, am 1. September jetzt ist Herbstbeginn und dann haben wir irgendwie zehn unterschiedliche Accounts geschrieben, je es ist Herbst. Und die haben auch einen eigenen Hashtag gehabt und die haben das alles gleich verwendet. Am anderen Tag haben sie unterschiedliche Accounts angeschrieben, vor allem Politiker, Journalisten und Medienaccounts, ob Merkel noch eine Amtszeit schafft. Also damals so, was soll das jetzt? Also ich, keine Ahnung, also ich glaube nicht, dass es wirklich einen Effekt gehabt hat. Aber tatsächlich waren es halt irgendwie so 10.000, so zehn Prozent, die tatsächlich inhaltlich irgendeinen Sinn gemacht haben. Manche Politiker haben auch darauf reagiert, dass man hat gesehen, dass es irgendeinen Erfolg gehabt hat. Also sie haben zumindest Leute erreicht. Und das andere ist, was sie haben halt auch versucht, indem sie Replays schreiben, eine größere Reichweite zu erzeugen, aber inhaltlich war es halt so schwach, dass ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass es irgendeinen Effekt hat. Vor allem, wenn ich mir anschaue, dass diese rechte Glase auf Twitter mit 10.000 bis 15.000 Accounts Hunderttausende Tweets veröffentlichen, die halt wesentlich radikaler und konkreter sind, als das, was diese Treuhlfabrik schraubtiziert hat.
Aber jetzt bin ich an einem interessanten Punkt, weil einerseits hat Katascha gerade gesagt, naja, irgendwie dieser einzelne Account, das geht eigentlich gar nicht. Und du sagst jetzt aber, naja, so irgendwie diese 10.000 Tweets, meine Güte. Um mal kurz abzubiegen vom, man ist persönlich betroffen von Hass, das andere Nummer, sondern dieses politische Einflussnahme, findet das statt? Also mal abgesehen davon, ob es jetzt moralisch vertretbar ist und dass man das sozusagen doof findet. Aber habt ihr das Gefühl, dass Hades wirklich alles macht, was man ihm zuschreibt, also die Grenzen ausweiten, Dinge extremer machen, tatsächlich irgendwie politisches Agenda? Also man könnte jetzt vermuten, wenn nur genug Accounts fragen, ob Angela Merkel noch eine Amtszeit macht, dann ist es vielleicht tatsächlich irgendwann eine Frage im Raum, ist es jetzt soweit? Haltet ihr das für reell, dass da ein Effekt ist, auf die mindestens Medienwelt?
Das ist absolut gar keine Diskussion heutzutage mehr, dass Social-Media-Debatten nicht vollkommen die öffentliche Debatte in jedem politischen Bereich sprengen können. Wir hatten so viele gute Initiativen in den vergangenen Jahren, wo beispielsweise ein Hashtag, wo viele Leute zugeschrieben haben, dann dafür gesorgt hat, dass ein Thema quasi das komplette Jahr oder den kompletten Sommer dominiert hat. Und das waren ja auch viele gute Initiativen. Ich bin überzeugt davon, dass jede Partei sich dessen bewusst ist, was Social Media für einen Effekt haben kann. Deshalb gehen heutzutage Parteien, adressieren auch gezielt ihre Unterstützer und Wähler und rufen dazu auf, dass sie auch in Social Media selbst aktiv werden und Freunde mobilisieren für was auch immer, um zur Wahl zu gehen oder zu einer Demo. Wenn man das wirklich in einem großen Rahmen gemacht hätte, gehen wir mal davon aus, bei der Treu-Fabrik wären zigtausende Leute beschäftigt und die hätten das alle gemacht, dann wäre das ein Thema gewesen. Wenn jeder Journalist 20 Fragen bekommt von Accounts, die vertrauenswürdig aussehen, es steht immer so, Angela Merkel sah letzte Woche sehr schlecht aus bei einem Interview, dann ist das irgendwann auch ein Titelthema in der Zeitung, mit Sicherheit. So funktioniert nämlich auch Öffentlichkeitsarbeit heutzutage. Und gerade darüber sollten wir uns im Klaren werden und auch solche Sachen. Also ich meine, wir haben jetzt über Socialbots gesprochen, die Accounts schreiben. Ich glaube, da ist die Technik einfach noch nicht so weit, dass man das so wirklich gut hinkriegt, dass man es auch nicht erkennt. Eine andere Frage sind ja auch gekaufte Likes und so weiter. Also es ist ja technisch viel trivialer möglich. Und bis vor kurzem habe ich noch vor jeder Wahl Rankings in der Zeitung gesehen. Ich finde die immer mega albern. Wie viele Likes hat welcher Spitzen Politiker auf Facebook? Wo ich mir denke so, what the fuck, das interessiert mich doch überhaupt nicht. Weil man kann mit ein paar Euro kann man sich das Ding halt hoch ranken. Und das ist leider momentan immer noch so die die Kenntnis statt Debatte, die wir vor Wahl kämpfen haben. Und ich glaube für jemanden, der sich noch nie darüber Gedanken gemacht hat, ob das jetzt manipuliert ist oder nicht, da macht das totalen Eindruck, wenn man sieht, oh, dieses Video hatte jetzt schon so viele Views. Oder diese Politiker-Person, die hat jetzt so viele Likes. Das muss jemand sein.
Aber kann man das, man kann es auch nicht ganz ignorieren. Also weil auch die die guten Bewegungen haben ja dadurch, sind dadurch zur Bewegung geworden, dass da halt viele Likes dran waren. Das ist ja letztlich das Entscheidende.
Ja klar, also das finde ich, ist halt immer so schwierig, abzugrenzen, wem vertraue ich und wem vertraue ich nicht. Und warum vertraue ich jemanden? Also ich fand das ganz interessant. Ich war mal auf einer Konferenz, da waren viele Leute, die hatten alle einen Twitter-Account und wie das so ist. Man vernetzt sich dann und wiederfolgt jedem. Und dann sagt jemand zu mir mit 100.000 Followern so, boah krass, du hast aber viele Follower. Ich so, hey, du hast 100.000. Und der so, ja, aber deine sind echt. Ich so, wie, woran siehst du das jetzt? Der so, ja, guck mal, du hast krasse Interaktionen zu allem, was du schreibst. Und dann gucke ich auf seinen Account tatsächlich. Der hat 100.000 Follower, aber halt wie mal so drei, wenn er irgendwie drei Sternchen irgendwie hat unter seinem Post, ist der halt schon gut gelaufen. Und das fand ich halt interessant, dass es halt auch in anderen Regionen der Welt, das war eine Internationalkonferenz, halt total üblich ist, dass man halt so ein bisschen sich seinen Account pusht.
Ja, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob wir für das Chaosradio nochmal das so eine Sache aufmachen mussten, was eigentlich Hatespeech mit Trollarmeen zu tun hat. Also Hatespeech ist eigentlich so ein individuelles Ding. Und diese Trollarmeen, im Worst-Cash-Verbreiten, sie hat eine Menge an sogenannten falschen Nachrichten, an Fake News, die mit manipulierender Absicht irgendwie in die Welt gesetzt werden. Aus ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen. Von der Theorie her und von der Praxis ist es, glaube ich, so, dass sozusagen diese Manipulation von allen Seiten kommen könnte, aber natürlich am meisten von Herausforderern kommt. Weil die natürlich normalerweise von den etablierten Medien ein Stück weit ausgeschlossen sind und gerade halt die neuen Medien nutzen und immer genutzt haben, um Inhalte publik zu machen. Das hat theoretisch früher auch die Linke mit in die Medien und so. Aber halt nicht so krass über soziale Netzwerke. Und ich glaube, so ein Problem zum Beispiel der Grünen ist halt, dass sie halt über Jahrzehnte die Digitalisierung abgelehnt haben und die digitalen Medien und jetzt erst Smartphones kaufen. Zum Teil, ich kenne Leute, die gehören dazu und die sozusagen das wirklich nicht... Also man braucht auch eine Weile, eben diese Welt so ein bisschen versteht, eben diese Algorithmen und diese Logiken so ein bisschen für sich nutzen kann und so.
Aber ich möchte zu dem, was du am Anfang gesagt hast, zurückkommen, also dass du das trennst zwischen Trollermähen und Hatespeech, weil gefühlte Wahrheit kommt aus derselben Ecke und hat dieselben Ziele, Leute mundtot machen.
Na, aber ich glaube, es ist ein grundsätzlicher Unterschied, ob man wirklich aus emotionalen Gründen hasst oder ob man sozusagen aus politisch-strategischen Gründen zum Beispiel Wahrheiten in Frage stellt.
These, die Troll-Armänen, falls es sie wirklich gibt, dienen dazu da, um Menschen dazu, ich sage es mal einfach so, in Befähigen, Hatespeech zu machen. Das sind ja geile Aussichten.
Das ist so, als wenn ich auf einer Party bin, und ich bin der Einzige, der redet laut. Ich falle unangenehm auf, weil ich rede so lauf. Und wenn ich einfach die Musik aufdrehe und dadurch alle zwinge, so ein bisschen lauter zu reden, dann schreien sich plötzlich alle an. Also das ist jetzt mal so einfach verständlich, wie man das Raumklima verändern kann, dadurch, dass man auch irgendwo den Ton setzt.
Aber lasst euch dieses Bild, wenn ihr nichts irgendwie so gehört habt, nehmt dieses Bild mit soziale Netzwerke als Partyraum, wo jemand die Musik unangenehm laut macht. Ich finde, das funktioniert auf sehr vielen Ebenen sehr, sehr, sehr gut. Und wir machen an dieser Stelle noch eine kleine Pause. Mit Musik! Was sonst im Partyraum? Wir machen sie aber leise, nicht so laut. Sie kommt von Aries Beats, Retrowave heißt der Track, den wir gleich hören wollen. Da gibt es gleich noch die Nerd News. Und nachdem wir jetzt darüber gesprochen haben, was und wer und wie und viel und wenig und direkt, wollen wir gleich drüber sprechen, was man vielleicht dagegen macht. Retro Wave von Aries Beats hier beim Chaos Radio Live auf dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Das sind das Chaos Radio Wäre, wenn es noch ein paar Nerd News gäbe und die werden heute präsentiert und wurden geschrieben von Danimo.
Die Mitarbeiter proteste gegen die Beteiligung am Pentagon Cloud Computing Projekt Jedi haben nichts genutzt. Die Microsoft Führung will an den Geschäften mit dem US-amerikanischen Militär festhalten. Dies verkündete Brad Smith, der Microsoft Chef-Anwalt im Unternehmensblock. Während er dort diplomatisch für den Standpunkt des US-Konzerns argumentierte, wird er in einem Interview mit der New York Times deutlicher. Microsoft sei in den Vereinigten Staaten geboren, habe seinen Stammsitz dort und sei mit allen Vorteilen groß geworden, die das Land zu bieten habe. Google hatte sich ebenfalls nach starken Mitarbeiterprotesten vor Kurzem aus der Bewerbung um Jedi zurückgezogen und nannte Verstöße gegen interne Ethikrichtlinien als Grund. Jedi alleine hat einen Umfang von 10 Milliarden US-Dollar. Der Bundesrat will nicht länger hinnehmen, dass Internetanbieter mit schnellen Anbindungen werben, die sie in der Praxis nicht erbringen. Er richtet sich nun mit einer Entschließung an die Bundesregierung. Die soll prüfen, ob erheblichen Unterschieden zwischen Werbung und tatsächlicher Leistung, Preisnachlässe oder Schadenersatzansprüche durchsetzbar sind. Der Vorstoß des Bundesrates hat aber keine direkten Konsequenzen. Die Bundesregierung muss die Forderungen nicht umsetzen und es gibt keine Frist zur Prüfung der Fragen. Die Bundesregierung will die zentrale Hackerbehörde CITES im kommenden Jahr erheblich besser ausstatten. Für ihre Aktivitäten sollen 36, 7 Millionen Euro bereitgestellt werden. Damit wächst das Budget im Vergleich zu diesem Jahr um rund ein Viertel an. Das hat Netzpolitik Org recherchiert. Ganz oben auf der Liste der staatlichen Hacker steht ein Supercomputer, der beim Knacken von Passwörtern helfen soll. CITES wurde vor eineinhalb Jahren gegründet, um Polizei und Geheimdienste bei der technischen Überwachung zu unterstützen.
Chaosradio 251, uns ist gerade das Pad abgestürzt. Alles was jetzt passiert, passiert aus meinem Kopf. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und wir sprechen heute über Hass im Netz mit Julia Krüger, Katharina Nocun und Luca Hammer. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück. Vielen Dank, mir wurde ein Pad gereicht. Wir wollen jetzt drüber reden, was man gegen Hass im Netz vielleicht tun kann. Und da würde ich ja zuallererst vermuten, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, wie man das angeht. Das eine ist, wir filtern das alles automatisch weg. Und das andere ist, wir beschließen gesetzlich, es darf keinen Hass mehr im Netz geben. Was ist eure Lieblingsvariante? Keiner.
Ich kann dir meinen kleinen Überblick geben. Nicht darf, nur ergänzt mich, okay? Also ich meine, das, was wir im Moment haben, sind ja sozusagen diverse Versuche, es wegzufiltern oder wegzulöschen, je nachdem, wie man es betrachtet. Wir haben einerseits sozusagen das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz seit Januar diesen Jahres in Kraft, was die großen Plattformanbieter verpflichtet dazu, nach Nutzermeldung eingegangenen Hate Speech zu löschen, in relativ kurzen Fristen.
Also es sind zwei Hürden. Es muss jemand melden.
Es muss auch jemand melden.
Und dann muss es juristisch wasserdicht Hate Speech sein?
Na leider nicht. Also juristisch wasserdicht wäre ganz toll. Aber dann müssten es auch Gerichte entscheiden. Oder momentan sollen es halt Facebook-Mitarbeiter entscheiden. Die wurden zwar relativ viel aufgestockt, aber insgesamt gab es gerade in der letzten Sitzungswoche Berichte. Oder es gab über den Sommer hinweg gab es die ersten Evaluationsberichte von den großen Plattformen. Das sah dieses Gesetz auch vor. Also dieses Gesetz sollte zwei Sachen machen. Es sollte einerseits sozusagen das sogenannte Beschwerdemanagement von den großen Plattformen einheitlich und konsistent machen und auch dem deutschen Recht anpassen. Und zum zweiten die Menge an strafbaren Inhalten in sozialen Netzwerken reduzieren. Was die Menge angeht, kann man glaube ich gar nicht sagen. Weil dadurch, dass unklar ist, wie viel es überhaupt an strafbaren Inhalten gibt, kann man auch nicht genau sagen, wie viel davon jetzt gelöscht wurde. Und man kann leider auch nicht sagen, ob das, was gelöscht wurde, eigentlich jetzt strafbar war oder nicht, weil es kein Mensch überprüft. Das ist sozusagen das Problem.
Sobald er strafbar war, hast du gerade gesagt, dass soziale Netzwerke Dinge aus dem Internet löschen und hinterher niemand guckt, ob es gerechtfertigt war oder nicht?
Das ist ja das Problem, dass sozusagen, dass ich das halt keine Gerichte mache, sondern eben Plattformanbieter, die das auch nicht weiter an Gericht leiten oder an die Polizei, was man natürlich hätte theoretisch machen können, um so ein bisschen Überblick zu behalten, was mit dem Netz überhaupt los ist. Einfach nur die Vorgabe war, okay, was sozusagen von Nutzerinnen und Nutzern gemeldet wird und was die Plattform als nach dem deutschen Strafgesetz, also nach den Straftatbeständen dieses NetzDG aufgezählt hat. Darunter fällt, das wird gelöscht und bisher gibt es auch keine wirksamen Wiederrufsverfahren oder so. Das soll jetzt theoretisch verbessert werden. Aber insgesamt weiß keiner, ob das gelöscht wurde, auch strafbar war oder nicht. Das ist sozusagen, ist das blöde an der ganzen Nummer. Das ist privatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung.
Aber gibt es, es gibt immer wieder Fälle, wo Leute, die sich quasi nicht zur Schuld haben kommen lassen, auch gesperrt wurden zum Beispiel, oder wo die den Tweets weggelöscht wurden. Ist das auf einen Missbrauch, das Netz-CG dann zurückzuführen?
Na insgesamt gibt es im Moment vor allem nicht viele Übersicht. Also sozusagen, es gibt insgesamt relativ wenig Fälle, die bekannt geworden sind. Und da, wo es schief gegangen ist, das waren meistens Accounts, die halt schon relativ populär waren. Irgendwie Titanic oder so. Insgesamt gibt es halt weder Stellen, die bisher sozusagen die Meldungen überblixmäßig registriert haben, noch die sozusagen Meldungen entgegengenommen haben von Missbrauch. Also ich hatte relativ regelmäßig andere Fragen von Journalisten, ob ich sagen könnte, wie viel Missbrauch davor liegt oder so. Ich kenne keine Stelle, die Missbrauchsfälle sammelt.
Wir können vielleicht noch mal einen Schritt zurückgeben. Hat es das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz eigentlich gebraucht oder hätte eigentlich die Gesetzgebung, die es der Forschung gab, gereicht, um strafrechtlich relevante Inhalte, die Hate Speech sind, aus dem Netz zu nehmen?
Na, es ist ein bisschen komplizierter. Also natürlich waren die Inhalte der Forschung strafbar. Natürlich konnte man die zur Anzeige bringen. Natürlich konnten die deutschen Gerichte oder die Polizeibehörden aktiv werden. Sie stießen halt im Regelfall auf das Problem, dass seitens der großen Plattform nicht so viel Kooperation da war, dem ganzen nachzugehen. Das heißt, die meisten Fälle versandeten irgendwo in irgendwelchen Briefkästen.
Warte, wir hatten also vorher die Situation, die sozialen Netzwerke machen nichts. Also jetzt mal übertrieben gesprochen. Und jetzt haben wir die Situation, die sozialen Netzwerke löschen alles.
Na, alles löschen sie nicht so. Sie löschen unterschiedlich viel. Und sie löschen das auch manchmal nach den eigenen Hausregeln. Manchmal nach dem Netz, die gehe. Und insgesamt ist es sozusagen nicht groß kohärenter als zuvor. Es soll jetzt theoretisch alles verbessert werden. Aber man muss halt sagen, dass das ganze Verfahren natürlich an und für sich nie wieder geeignet sind, geeignet ist, um juristisch klare Sache zu machen. Noch ist es geeignet, der Menge an Hassrede oder was beizukommen. Und was halt tatsächlich noch wesentlich kritischer ist, ist, dass sowohl parallel zu der ganzen Diskussion alle großen Plattformen darin investiert haben, automatisierte Filterverfahren, Content-Management-Systeme zu entwickeln.
Waren wir gleich.
Was jetzt auch von europäischer Ebene natürlich gefordert wird.
Aber lass uns erstmal beim juristischen Teil bleiben. Luca, kann ich da noch irgendwie Anmerkungen?
Bei Twitter würde ich sagen, dass es Netz.DG grundsätzlich den Ablauf etwas verschlechtert hat, weil früher hat man halt melden können, ein Feed verstößt gegen die Twitter-Nutzungsbedingungen. Also ergreift Personen, was auch immer. Die waren relativ weich formuliert, was natürlich wieder ein Problem für sich ist, aber grundsätzlich hat man alles immer relativ einfach melden können. Seitennetz.DG muss man bei Twitter jetzt immer in Paragrafen angeben. Also man muss jetzt sagen, gegen welches Gesetz verstößt der Inhalt jetzt überhaupt? Und das macht es teilweise wirklich schwierig, Inhalte zu melden, weil man da gar nicht mehr genau weiß, mehr gegen was verstößt der jetzt eigentlich. Vor allem, wenn halt so Massenaktionen sind, wenn dann irgendwie 5000 Accounts, ja, das ist immer übertrieben, wenn ein paar Hundert Accounts sich angreifen. Und es ist jetzt, die sind nicht greifbar. Also es sind ganz viele Meldungen, die eigentlich problematisch sind. Aber es sind nicht alles Meldungen, die gegen einen Paragraphen verstoßen. Und dann kannst du das nicht wirklich melden. Und natürlich auch, selbst wenn man es meldet, ist es nicht so, dass das Wetter dann tatsächlich löscht.
Man muss vielleicht dazusagen, dass natürlich auch dadurch, dass man sich mal anzeigt, sondern nur meldet, ein ganz großer Teil von einem Opferschutz wegfällt. Weil früher war das natürlich, wenn mal jemand verurteilt, war auch gut für die Opfer, dass mal Recht gesprochen wurde und auch das Recht weiterentwickelt wurde und hat gesagt wurde, okay, das ist legitim, das ist nicht legitim. Und hier hat jemand Unrecht erfahren und das Feld hat jetzt alles weg. Also im Prinzip...
Also das beste Denkbare ist jetzt, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen weniger wird. Selbst das ist nicht sicher.
Das passiert ja glaube ich nicht viel. Es gibt keine Abschreckung.
Ja, also ich hab da so einen ganz konkreten Fall. Ich hab bei Facebook mal vor der Landtagswahl in Schleswig-Holstein so ein bisschen geguckt, wie ich das so mache. Was macht die Partei so? Und hab da so gesehen, da ist ein Facebook-Post mit einem SA-Symbol. Und da so, hm, SA-Symbol in Deutschland, ist das nicht verboten?
Gibt es sogar einen eigenen Paragraf dafür?
Gibt es, tatsächlich hab ich das auch rausgefunden. Und dann so, ja, okay, was mach ich jetzt? Und dann war Möglichkeit A, ich melde es bei Facebook, wird vielleicht gesperrt, vielleicht auch nicht. In dem Fall war ich aber der Überzeugung, das ist für mich so ein krasser, ja, Gesetzesbruch einfach. Also da steht eine Strafe drauf. Und man darf das Symbol nur verwenden, wenn man es eben aus, weiß ich nicht, um die Geschichte zu erklären. Oder, weiß ich nicht, im Rahmen, ganz eng gesteckten Rahmen darf man es verwenden. Der Facebook-Post kam dem natürlich nicht gerecht. Und deshalb, ja, hab ich das dann angezeigt, wo hab's gemeldet. In dem Fall von solchen Sachen ist es auch so, dass du dich nicht, also du bist nicht das Opfer der Straftat, sondern es ist ja quasi etwas, dem muss die Polizei nachgehen, wenn sie Kenntnis davon hat. Und das hat aber auch recht lange gedauert, bis dann überhaupt irgendetwas passiert ist. Also meine Erfahrung ist da auch, dass vielleicht nicht alle Polizeibehörden da angemessen ausgestattet, ausgebildet sind, um dagegen vorzugehen. Ich hatte ein anderes Mal einen Fall während des Landtagswahlkampfes in Niedersachsen. Da hab ich für die Piraten kandidiert. Da hat uns jemand auch Drohungen geschickt per E-Mail. Zwei Schüsse einmal zwischen die Augen und Tod. Seid ihr oder so was? Genau, das war für die Polizei auch ein bisschen überfordernd. Interessant fand ich aber auch, dass ich bei einem anderen Fall, den ich hatte, dann auch zur Polizei gegangen bin. Wir haben das dann zur Anzeige gebracht. Dann hatte ich erst mal ein bisschen moralische Gewissensriss. Weil ich dachte, du bist ja gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Jetzt müssen jetzt die Vorratsdaten von diesen Menschen vielleicht rausgeholt werden, um herauszufinden, wer es ist. Stellt sich aber hinterher raus, oh nee, das war sein richtiger Name. Und wenn man den in der Suchmaschine eingibt, findet man ein Bild von ihm und seiner Frau, wie sie eine Wurst gekauft haben bei einem deutschen Fleischer. Wie sie ganz stolz diese Wurst in die Kamera zeigen, weil er hat in Spanien gelebt. Diese Praxiserfahrung der Anzeige ist auch noch mal eine ganz andere Sache. Eine Meldung ist schnell gemacht als Opfer. Aber andererseits denkt man auch, habe ich demjenigen gezeigt, was das für mich bedeutet hat? Nein, eigentlich nicht. Vielleicht wird sein Post gesperrt. Vielleicht wird sein Account gesperrt. Gut, macht er sich jetzt einen neuen. Aber der macht doch weiter wie bisher. Da würde ich auch jedem dazu raten, wenn es wirklich was Krasses ist und man gerade die Zeit übrig hat. Oder vielleicht ein bisschen Geld für einen Anwalt ist leider nicht kostenlos. Macht das einfach mal. Also es ist halt auch eine wichtige Erfahrung für sich selbst als Opfer zu sagen, ich schluck das jetzt nicht alles immer runter, ich lass das nicht mit mir machen, sondern erklär das mal bitte der Polizei.
Weil der Untertitel der Sendung ist, wie man die gesellschaftliche Debatte stärkt, ohne in die Meinungsfreiheit anzugreifen. Das geht mit dem Netz-CG schon mal nicht.
Nee, gar nicht. Also das ging aber vorher schon nicht. Also vorher war es ja schon so, dass Facebook nach Hausregeln entschieden hat, das ist erlaubt, das ist verboten. Gewalt, da ist man Großzüger bei Facebook, was halt auch so mit dem US-amerikanischen, ja vielleicht Verständnis davon, was im öffentlichen Raum akzeptabel ist, zusammenhängt. Beispielsweise Nippel von Frauenstille. Frauen geht gar nicht. Und da gab es mal einen ganz interessanten Fall, auch noch vor dem Netz-CG. Da gab es eine Seite, die hat sich ja so mit der AfD oder mit rechten Gruppen befasst, auch viel gepostet. Unter anderem satirische Beiträge von Extra 3. Da war auf einem Bild Hitler zu sehen in der Sprechblase, der sagt dann, ich bin zwar kein Nazi, aber... Die nächste Sprechblase, das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen. Das wurde dann von ganz vielen Leuten gemeldet. Wir haben das nachher dann untersucht in der Gruppe und haben gesehen, da gibt es gezielt Accounts auf Facebook von Rechten, die sagen, wir melden jetzt Gruppen oder Einzelpersonen, die uns unangenehm sind. Und zwar so oft, bis wir irgendwann an einen Sachbearbeiter gelangen bei Facebook, der wenig genug Bescheid weiß, um zu sagen, ach, das sperre ich jetzt mal. Und das ist in dem Fall dann auch passiert. Wegen einem extra drei Satire-Post wurde dann ein ganzer Account quasi hops genommen. Und zum Glück konnte das wieder rückgängig machen. Wie gesagt, in dem Fall war natürlich dann auch das Glück, dass da eine gewisse öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit da ist. Aber es ist vorher schon passiert. Das Problem ist, dass das NetzDG eben natürlich die Anreize verschiebt. Wenn ich als Betreiber weiß, da ist eine hohe Geldstrafe, die mich erwartet, wenn ich das nicht rechtzeitig lösche und ich bin mir nicht sicher, bzw. ich habe unterbezahlte Mitarbeiter, die sich ganz sicher nicht sicher sind, weil die keine juristische Vorbildung haben, dann nehme ich in Kauf, dass einfach mehr Sachen weggeschüttet werden, weil ich einfach die finanziellen Risiken scheue.
Jetzt sind wir sozusagen in diesem strafrechtlich relevanten Inhalt. Wie könnte man die juristisch unterbinden? Geht nicht so geil, das den Plattformen zu überlassen, ist auch nicht so gut. Was ich mich häufig gefragt habe, ist, von dem, was sie auch so erzählt haben, es gibt immer diese Einzeltäter, also jemand bedroht mich, jemand stalkt mich, aber das andere Phänomen ist ja auch immer, dass es dann so Wellen gibt. Es ist halt nicht nur ein Account, sondern es gibt halt Ziele, und diese Ziele werden dann von mehreren Accounts, Sockenpuppen, Retweetbots angegriffen. Und ich jetzt, als der da kein Programmierer ist, und sozusagen nicht wirklich weiß, wie das funktioniert, fragt sich aber trotzdem, ließe sich das nicht irgendwie so automatisieren, also dass du als User in deinem sozialen Account so Schwellen anmachen kannst und sagen kannst, okay, ich weiß irgendwie einen normalen Tag, ich hab 200.000 Follower, krieg aber nur drei Likes. Wenn ich irgendwie an einem Tag mehr als zehn Replies kriege, dann mal so stopp irgendwie, dann halte die mal irgendwo vor, oder filter die automatisch. Was ich halt total witzig finde, ist auch, wo ist denn das auf manchen Zeitungsseiten gibt, also die so Foren haben, da funktioniert das schon relativ zuverlässig. Also wir zeigen dir hier diese drei Kommentare an, da gibt's so noch fünf, die sind relativ wahrscheinlich nicht so geil, weil da irgendwie Schimpfwörter drin vorkommt. Also es gibt ja so Automatismen. Warum gibt es sowas nicht in den sozialen Netzwerken in dieser Form? Also in Nutzerhand sozusagen. Also nicht das Netzwerk entscheidet, was gut ist, sondern gibt den Nutzer so die Möglichkeit, so grobe Algorithmen einzustellen, mit der Möglichkeit, sich alles anzugucken, aber trotzdem so eine Art Firewall einzubauen. Gibt es da überhaupt Bestrebungen oder ist das zu schwierig?
Also die gab es ja mal ganz stark, gerade bei Twitter, also diese ganze Muting-Funktion zum Beispiel, dass man sowohl einzelne Hashtags, einzelne Personen oder auch einzelne Worte muten kann.
Aber da musst du ja immer noch konkret werden. Da musst du ja sagen, also dieses Hashtag und diese Person will ich nicht mehr hören.
Ja, aber jetzt mal um ein konkretes Beispiel zu nennen, also was eigentlich, glaube ich, wo ich mich mal ganz viel mit beschäftigen muss, war aus Versehen, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich daran erinnerst, an diese krasse Diskussion um den Jacob Applebaum drin herum, wo die ganze Szene irgendwie auseinandergeflogen ist und plötzlich irgendwie alle so und das Problem ist ja sozusagen, das hatten wir vorhin schon, dass das so, wenn man die ganze Zeit nur auf einem bestimmten Erregungslevel gehalten wird, ist es ganz schwer, es auf den Abstand zu nehmen. Und da sozusagen in so einer Situation zum Beispiel, damals gab es das noch nicht, die Chance haben, okay, erst mal alles, was hier mit Jacob Applebaum zu tun hat, erst mal auszustellen, hält ja sozusagen sehr viel Entspannung für diejenigen reingebracht, die entweder anders arbeiten wollen.
Man muss jetzt ganz kurz sagen, relativ prominente Figuren, Hackerkreisen, relativ harte Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe. Und darüber hat sich dann diese Szene, also am konkreten Fall und dann auch, was bedeutet das eigentlich, hat sich die Szene sehr entzweit, entdreit entviert, kann man sagen.
Genau, weil das natürlich auch gerade bei allen Leuten, bei allen Frauen, die sozusagen vielleicht mal was Ähnliches erlebt haben, es hat einfach unglaublich viele Emotionen ausgelöst. Es gab keine Chance, sich davor zu schützen, außer Twitter auszumachen, was für viele Menschen einfach beruflich keine Option mehr ist. Und da ist es sozusagen eine ganz kluge Sache von Twitter gewesen, dass, glaube ich, auf die Forschung von Karen Sinders zurückgegangen ist. Die ist eine Gamergate-Forscherin, die sich sehr viel damit beschäftigt hat, wie man eigentlich Nutzer dazu bringen kann, selbstbestimmt ihren Diskursraum zu gestalten. Darauf geht es zurück. Ähnlich ist da Mozilla mit dem Choral-Projekt in New York. Die haben Technologien entwickelt, wie man das auf Blogs so machen kann, dass gute Argumente und gute Diskutanten hochgerankt werden können. Es gab mal IMSEE, eine Facebook-ähnliche Plattform, wo man verschiedene Optionen hatte, sich Kommentare anzeigen zu lassen. Aber all das wurde eigentlich auch ein bisschen durch das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz zunichte gemacht, dass gesagt wurde, wir wollen eine Lösung für alle, eine, die dem Rechtsstaat genügt usw. Da wurden eigentlich konstruktivere Ansätze zunichte gemacht. Wenn man jetzt mal bei der Frage bleibt, wie kriegt man es hin, dass mehr gute Inhalte im Diskurs sind, könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, die großen Plattformen sollten nicht bloß Inhalte höher ranken, die viel Interaktion hervorrufen, sondern wo die Interaktion möglichst divers ist. Also wo die sozialen Gruppen oder die kulturellen Gruppen verschieden sind, also wo nicht nur Nazis einen Inhalt teilen, sondern wo möglicherweise unterschiedliche gesellschaftliche Gruppen Inhalt wichtig finden.
Aber wäre das dann nicht...
Und sowas wird gerade erdacht, das weiß ich. Das wäre auch eine Netzwerkgenuine Methode, um Inhalte anders zu steuern. Aber da stoßen sich im Regelfall alle Juristen, die sagen, wir wollen deutsches Recht durchgesetzt haben und nicht irgendwie anders Inhalte steuern oder so.
Wir können ja die deutschen Juristen jetzt mal deutschen Juristen sein lassen. Luca, vielleicht auch noch mal fragen wollen, einen Hate Shitstorm, würdest du sagen, man könnte den erkennen und auch semiautomatisch ablocken? Also wie gesagt, nicht inhaltlich, sondern sozusagen, dass man so Algorithmen hat, die sagen, na, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so geil, ich blende dir das mal aus, falls du es doch sehen willst, klick hier.
Bin ich, bin ich sehr kritisch. Also Greta versucht ja ein paar so Sachen. Ich weiß nicht, sie haben einmal den Qualitätsfilter und dann haben sie noch irgendwas für die Notifications, wo sie darüber gehen, Accounts, die häufig geblockt werden oder Accounts, die ständig Replies an andere Accounts schreiben, aber nie was zurückbekommen, dass die quasi automatisiert ausgefiltert werden. Also weil die halt einfach abusive Verhaltensweisen an den Tag legen und dann kann man die halt automatisiert etwas ausblenden, nicht komplett. Also sie sind grundsätzlich noch da. Das hilft etwas. Also das habe ich selber manchmal ausprobiert, wenn besonders viel am Twitter-Volumen gerade war, dass ich das so ein bisschen ausblende. Und dann ist es schon einmal ruhiger, dann kann man mit dem Rest besser umgehen. Aber bei Twitter ist dann das große Problem, die Replies sind ja trotzdem noch da. Und die Leute, die einem folgen, wenn sie auf ein Feed klicken, sehen trotzdem noch das Zeug. Manchmal wird es jetzt auch schon wieder versteckt, dann ist mehr, mehr Menschen oder mehr Replies anzeigen. Grundsätzlich bei Shitstorms, im Nachhinein kann man die eigentlich sehr gut analysieren. Also wenn es jetzt gerade gegen eine Person geht, dann kann man halt eben den Usernamen verwenden, beziehungsweise noch ein paar Begriffe rundherum. Und dann kann man sich anschauen, wir hatten sich da alle beteiligt. Aber das jetzt in Echtzeit zu machen und sofort zu sagen, okay, das ist ein positiver, es ist ein negativer Aufregungsschurm oder was auch immer, halte ich für sehr schwierig. Und man kann das halt für Einzelpersonen, kann man tatsächlich dann auch Bloglisten erstellen oder Mute-Listen, um es für die Person selber etwas erträglicher zu machen, aber das hilft halt der Gesamtdiskussion auch noch nicht.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, persönlich, also ich hab da überhaupt gar keine Hoffnung in irgendwelche technischen Lösungen, weil ganz ehrlich, das Problem sitzt ja leider vor der Tastatur so und alles, was das wegfiltert, ja, soll mir ein gutes Gefühl geben, aber ja, also ich muss sagen, so in den letzten zehn Jahren hab ich gelernt, damit sehr viel lockerer umzugehen, was nicht unbedingt erstrebenswert ist, ja, weil man sollte ja auch nicht sagen, nur derjenige sollte sich noch öffentlich äußern, der irgendwann, ja, das halt ausblenden kann. So sollte es ja nicht sein, aber ja, ich glaub, ich würd auch keine Filter installieren wollen, die mir quasi vorenthalten, was da passiert. Also wenn ich merke, da ist halt grad, braut sich was zusammen, dann guck ich einfach ein, zwei Tage nicht in Social Media rein, Punkt. Wobei ich auch sagen muss, ist was vollkommen anderes, wenn man eine öffentliche Person ist, als wenn man jetzt beispielsweise irgendwie 17 ist und irgendwie fünf Leute aus der eigenen Klasse schreiben öffentlich über einen im Internet, du bist scheiße. Dann ist es halt kein Shitstorm von 5000 Leuten. Ja, aber es sind vielleicht die 5000 Leute, die mir in meinem Leben am meisten wehtun können, zu einer Zeit, wo ich unglaublich verletzlich bin. Und ich stelle mir das sehr schwierig vor, das halt irgendwie technisch lösen zu wollen. Ich wäre auch sehr kritisch gegenüber irgendwelchen Filtern, die vielleicht ranken nach Diversität usw. Also so begrüßenswert vielleicht die Effekte im Großen und Ganzen sind. Ich würde mir als Nutzer bevormundet vorkommen. Also ich möchte die Möglichkeit haben, selber solche Einstellungen vorzunehmen, wenn ich sie möchte. Aber was ich grundsätzlich bei Facebook gerne hätte, wäre einfach einen vollkommen selbstbestellten Filter zu 100%.
Aber das ist ja das, was ich gefragt habe. Ich meinte ja exakt nicht, sollen die Netzwerke das irgendwie für mich festlegen, sondern warum ist es, genau was du gesagt hast, warum ist es nicht so, dass ich als User die Möglichkeit habe, dieses Erlebnis freier zu gestalten? Also eben halt mich zu entscheiden, ich möchte gerne diesen Filter, den ihr mir da anbietet, anwenden oder nicht. Und wann immer der Filter anschickt, auch dass ich jedes Mal die Gelegenheit habe zu sagen, ja okay, danke, aber ich will trotzdem reingucken.
Ja, also ich hätte gerne die volle Wahlmöglichkeit. Das wäre so die beste Lösung, finde ich. Weil dann kann man auch selber gucken, was funktioniert für mich persönlich und was funktioniert nicht und kann es vielleicht anpassen.
Ne, das frage ich gleich. Wir hören jetzt noch Musik und dann frage ich euch mal nach Klarnahmenzwang. Weil das ist ja, also wenn die Gesetzgebung nicht funktioniert und der automatische Filter nicht, dann gibt es ja Leute, die sagen, der Klarnahmenzwang, der wird auf jeden Fall alles so machen, dass es unfassbar gut wird. Aber bevor wir dieses Wundermittel ausprobieren, hören wir es den Starsong von Lee Rose Ware. So, ist ja nur noch eine halbe Stunde. Wir müssen dann gleich mal darüber reden, wie es denn jetzt in Zukunft eigentlich so wird mit diesem Netz, in dem es diesen ganzen Hass gibt, ob das so bleibt oder ob man das vielleicht alles anders machen kann. Aber vorher noch, also vor den großen Visionen, das kleine Wundermittel. Es gibt ja häufig Leute und also wirklich, das kommt aus den verschiedensten Ecken und auch immer wieder. Wer war denn das neulich? Irgendjemand hat neulich bei Twitter gesagt so, ja, wer unter Pseudonym antwortet, dem antworte ich gar nicht erst. Nur der Klarnamenzwang ist die reine Lehre und verhindert allen Hass im Netz. Und man mag man im Tonfall schon annehmen, dass ich nicht so ganz glaube, aber noch mal kurz, weil das ist schon was, wenn wir darüber reden. Das ist ja auch ein Argument, das immer kommt. Wir müssen es auch hier wenigstens kurz vorkommen lassen. Deswegen erstens an euch die Frage, was ist die Idee, also warum kommen Leute darauf, dass Klarnamenzwang möglicherweise für weniger Hass im Netz sorgen könnte?
Ja, so ein Vorurteil ist ja, dass der Hass nur daherkommt, dass man anonym ist. Das ist so eine grundsätzliche Annahme, bei der man sagt, naja, so ins Gesicht würde ich das jemandem ja nicht sagen. Und von daher, weil viele Leute auch online anders unterwegs sind mit Nicknames, ist dann der Verdacht oder der Schuldige schlecht gefunden, weil der kann ja unmöglich vor der Tastatur sitzen. Das liegt anscheinend daran, dass die Leute sich halt eben unter Pseudonym oder Anonym äußern können. Und das ist so eine der Standardvermutungen. Wobei man sagen muss, also da ist natürlich auch so ein Hintergedanke bei, je nachdem wer es sagt dabei. Man muss ja auch sagen, wenn wir alle mit Klarnamen im Netz unterwegs wären, das heißt mit Vornamen, Nachnamen überall angemeldet werden, dann wäre es ja für die Werbewirtschaft auch viel einfacher, uns alles Mögliche zu verkaufen. Das heißt, gerade wenn bestimmte Akteure, die auch ein gesundes Eigeninteresse in der Hinsicht dran haben, uns erzählen wollen, ja melde dich überall lieber mit Vornamen, Nachnamen, am besten noch mit Passnummer und Geburtstag an. Vorsicht.
Okay, aber wir haben heute schon auch konkret ein Beispiel gehört, dass Professor Doktor, ich schieß dich tot, durchaus im Klarnamen mit unterwegs ist. Was mich aber interessieren würde ist, eine von euch hatte mir im Vorfeld erzählt, es gab schon mal ein größeres Sozialexperiment, wo genau das ausprobiert worden ist, wo man dann mal gucken konnte, was bringt denn jetzt dieser Klarnamenzwang?
Ja, das war ich. Und zwar gab es mal einen Klarnamenzwang in sozialen Netzwerken und auf Internetseiten, die politische Nachrichten berichten, und zwar in Südkorea für ein paar Jahre. Und da gab es im Nachhinein auch ziemlich viel interessante Forschung, die haben sich angeguckt, hat denn das Aufkommen von Shitstorms oder von Hassbotschaften dann wirklich abgenommen dadurch. Und die kommen zu dem Ergebnis, nee, also wenn überhaupt, dann kann man sagen, vielleicht ein oder zwei Prozent weniger an Hassnachrichten, aber ob das jetzt darauf zurückzuführen ist, so kann man auch nicht genau sagen. Grundsätzlich haben die Studien alle gezeigt, dass wenn jemand wirklich Hass erfüllt ist und bereit ist, jemanden bestimmte Dinge vor den Lads zu knallen, dann macht er das mit und ohne Doktortitel, so wie in meinem Beispiel. Und das ist leider so. Und in Südkorea kommt auch noch mal dazu, dass die ganze Geschichte dieses Gesetzgebungsverfahrens auch recht krude war. Und zwar war der Auslöser ein veritabler Shitstorm, so einer der ersten größeren Shitstorms, die Südkorea erlebt hat. Und zwar hat jemand gefilmt, wie eine Hundehalterin in der Bahn unterwegs war und ihr Hund hat dann ein Geschäft verrichtet und sie ist dann einfach mit dem Hund rausgegangen und jemand hatte das gefilmt und ins Netz gestellt. Und diese Frau ist dann zum Hassobjekt der gesamten Nation geworden. Und daraufhin hat die Regierung dann gesagt, wir müssen jetzt was machen. Und das Interessante ist, dass das Gesetz, was dann danach beschlossen wurde, nicht nur beinhaltete, dass Internetseiten, die mehr als 300.000 Nutzer haben, dann Leute zwingen müssen, mit echten Namen sich anzumelden, sondern auch, dass man zwölf Tage vor der Wahl nur noch mit Klarnamen, also mit richtigen Namen, in Blogs und so weiter politische Kommentare oder Kommentare zu Kommentaren verfassen darf. Was ja durchaus ein politisches Geschmäckle hat. Genau, aber zum Glück gibt es ja die Klarnamenpflicht, wurde dann irgendwann auch abgeschafft in Südkorea. Und zwar war es so, dass es eine kleine Sicherheitslücke in einem Social-Network gab. Und daraufhin haben ganz viele Leute Daten rausgetragen. Das ist natürlich was komplett anderes, wenn ich da als Bibi Blocksberg registriert bin. Oder mit Vor- und Nachnamen. Und vielleicht noch Geburtsdatum und Passnummer. Und ja, das hat so die Einstellung zu solchen Fragen nachhaltig verändert. Ich muss zu meiner Schande gestehen, ich weiß nicht, wie es heute aussieht. Aber zu dieser Phase in Südkorea gibt es auf jeden Fall sehr gute Studien, die alle sagen, so ist Quatsch.
So, also da halte ich mal fest. Mit der juristischen Keule wird das nicht so richtig. Mit der automatischen technischen Lösung wird das auch nicht so richtig. Und Gottverdammt noch mal, der Klarnamenzwang bringt das auch nicht. Jetzt wollte ich gerade fragen, wie kriegen wir den Hass im Netz im Griff? Aber ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das die richtige Frage ist. Weil ich muss mal ein sehr altes Interview zitieren. Mit Glenn Greenwald hatten wir das mal. Also der Journalist, der diesnotenfalls mit sozusagen am Anfang verwaltet und den ans Licht gebracht hat. Und das war so ein Jahr oder zwei nach den Edward-Snoten-Enhüllungen. Und haben ihn gefragt, naja, also irgendwie, jetzt ist ja wirklich, also schwarz auf weiß, alles wird überwacht, Geheimdienste machen unsere Pakete auf und bauen Chips in den Computer rein, Mikrowellen strahlen, hören Handykabel ab. Also das Irrsinnigste, was man sich ausdenken kann, ist alles wahr. Und trotzdem gibt es Leute, die sagen, ja Überwachung ist auch so egal. Er sagt, naja, er geht davon aus, es gibt halt einfach so pro Gesellschaft so 20 bis 30 Prozent Leute, die merken es einfach nicht oder die werden vom System nicht genug unterdrückt, denen geht es gut. Man muss damit leben, dass die da sind. Und muss sich nur den Rest kümmern. Analog dazu, kann man Hass im Netz im Griff kriegen oder muss man einfach damit leben, dass man sagt, also früher haben die halt in den Stammtischkneipen vor sich hin abgehast, jetzt haben sie einfach eine öffentliche Bühne. Das ist halt so, wir müssen irgendwie alle resilient werden, damit umgehen oder kann man das irgendwie in den Griff bekommen, wie auch immer das aussehen soll. Hat jemand eine Lösung?
Also ich, ja danke, ich wird, also wir sind in letzter Zeit mal so zwei Sachen aufgefallen. Die werden Hass im Netz nicht eliminieren. Aber es geht ja auch nicht darum sozusagen, den Mund tot zu machen, sondern tatsächlich sozusagen eine Gesellschaft zu ermöglichen irgendwie. Also es geht darum, eine Balance zu haben. Ich meine, was natürlich total dämlich ist, wir reden jetzt seit zwei Jahren intensivst über Hass im Netz, über Hate Speech, über Bots, über alles Mögliche, über Inhalte, wo ich neugierig total eins auf die Decke gekriegt habe, weil ich sie auf Netzpolitik jetzt unliebsam bezeichnet habe. Also Inhalte, die wie Hass, wie terroristische Inhalte, wie Kinderpornografie, die im Regelfall sozusagen an hiesige Normen stoßen und die man gerne raus haben will. Und gleichzeitig haben wir halt sozusagen hier in Deutschland ein EU-Heberrecht, was gerade auf europäischer Ebene erweitert werden soll, was die Verbreitung von qualitativ hochwertigen Inhalten wie Presseartikeln, aber auch anderen Werken eigentlich reduzieren soll. Und es macht halt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass wir uns einerseits darüber aufregen, dass sozusagen die Netzwerke mit allem möglichen Scheiß geflutet werden. Und wir gleichzeitig sozusagen die Verbreitung von guten Inhalten künstlich behindern.
Warte, ich hab mich neulich zu was gelesen. Also gerade heute irgendjemand, der meinte so, na ja, es zeichnet sich langsam ab, dass die ganzen großen Medien Paywalls einmal, also man muss bezahlen, um Artikel zu lesen. Das heißt, es gibt ein wohlkuratiertes, gut schmeckendes Internet für alle Leute, die sich das leisten können und lasst den armen Pöbel doch einfach in den Hassnetzwerken abhängen.
Ja, aber wir haben halt sozusagen, ich weiß nicht genau, wir haben jetzt gestern schon wieder so eine Waage gehabt. Also ich sitze ja hier quasi, naja, also nicht offiziell für die SPD. Also ich bin ja auch grün, aber ich kooperiere auch mit den meisten bis auf die AfD. Also wie wir auch immer, auf jeden Fall gibt es sozusagen natürlich das Problem, dass es eine massive Unzufriedenheit der Menschen mit der Politik gibt. Und zwar glaube ich aus mehreren Gründen zu Recht. Also einerseits haben wir natürlich, seitdem wir das Netz haben und seitdem wir die Globalisierung haben, auf nationalstaatlicher Ebene ganz viel Handlungsoptionen eingeboost. Und es gehen ganz viele Sachen nicht voran und es macht die Leute unzufrieden. Wir brauchen für ganz viele wirtschaftliche und ökologische Probleme internationale Lösungen. Und gerade haben wir sozusagen ein internationales Spiel, wo sozusagen der Populismus zurückkehrt, wo die Kriegsbedrohungen zurückkehrt und wo alles andere als zufriedenstellend ist. Also ich verstehe die Unzufriedenheit von den Menschen so. Und ich glaube, dass man den Hass auch mal als einen Ausdruck von menschlichem Leid sehen muss. Und was mich in letzter Zeit auf der anderen Seite auch beschäftigt tatsächlich, war die Frage, was wäre eigentlich, wenn man mal nicht gegen den einzelnen Hater vorgehen würde, sondern die Masse an Hass aggregieren würde und mal gucken würde, hängt das zusammen mit bestimmten ökologischen Faktoren, zum Beispiel mit Lärm und Abgas. Wie ist das? Gibt es eigentlich einen Zusammenhang zwischen Aggression und der Grundversorgung von Menschen international? Wir haben heute soziale Netzwerke, die uns unglaublich sensible Analysen über Menschen ermöglichen und die werden aber eigentlich gegen Menschen verwendet. Was wäre eigentlich, wenn man sozusagen gucken würde, was drückt eigentlich dieser Hass aggregiert aus?
Du meinst, wenn man die soziale Netzwerke nicht dazu benutzen könnte, würde man sagen, was können wir ihnen am besten verkaufen, sondern was fehlt ihnen eigentlich?
Ja, also wenn man zum Beispiel, es gibt diese Abida, ein ganz tolles Forschungsnetzwerk, Abida heißt das, die machen so Big Data-Analysen aus einer disziplinären Perspektive und die hatten neulich eine ganz tolles Gutachten zum Thema Nudging. Und da war sozusagen ein Beispiel, Facebook ist in der Lage, Du müssen das Mikrofon ein bisschen eher wieder. Facebook ist in der Lage, heute sowas wie Selbstmordgefährdung zu erkennen. Und je nach Land können dann halt zum Beispiel Freunde informiert werden, dass die sich da mal melden oder könnte auch mal Sozialarbeiter vorbei geschickt werden oder auch Polizei oder auch, ich mein, man kann auch live gestreamt werden, dann kommt halt nur der Krankenwagen so, ne? Das ist richtig schlecht. Aber es gibt es halt in Amerika auch alles. Aber für mich ist sozusagen das eigentlich eine totale Ressourcenverschwendung und auch gefährlich, dass sozusagen so ein Unternehmen so auf Abweichungen wie Krankheit oder wie irgendwas anderes sozusagen drauf gehen kann. Aber natürlich, wenn Facebook, so wie Zuckerberg in seinem Manifest versprochen hat, in der Lage ist automatisiert, sowohl individuelle und kollektive Risiken zu erkennen, könnte man natürlich das auch wirklich benutzen, um herauszufinden, wo kommen die denn her, was könnte man sozusagen auf übergeordneter Ebene tun, um die Risiken für die einzelnen Menschen zu begrenzen, damit es denen besser geht.
Aber dahinter steckt ja sozusagen die optimistische Annahme, der Mensch hasst nicht, wenn es ihm nur gut genug geht.
Ich denke auf jeden Fall, dass sozusagen der Hass eine ganz normale Reaktion ist, wenn Menschen unter Druck, unter Existenzdruck sich fühlen und sie tun seit jeher irgendwie den nächstbesten Nachbarn als Hassobjekt identifizieren. Es ist sozusagen was relativ Normales. Es funktioniert aber sozusagen nicht, wenn eigentlich alle immer mehr unter Druck stehen.
Ja, also dem würde ich wieder sprechen. Also ich würde gerne so eine positive Einstellung haben und immer bei jedem, der mir schreibt, ach ja, morgen Gruppenvergewaltigung, 9 Uhr, wie immer, würde ich dann denken, oh ja, der ist bestimmt sehr missverstanden. Und eigentlich ist das ein total netter Mensch. Er lebt einfach nur in ganz schlimmen Bedingungen. Ja, also ich glaube, das ist gemischt. Also vielleicht teilweise Leute, denen geht es wirklich irgendwie wirtschaftlich schlecht. Aber es ist, mein Gott, mir ging es in meinem Leben auch nicht wirtschaftlich immer gut. Das ist trotzdem kein Grund, dann halt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, also gruppenbezogenen Hass raushängen zu lassen. Also eine Freundin von mir engagiert sich ganz stark im Bereich Diskriminierung von Muslimen. Was die abkriegt, ist nur ein Bruchteil von dem, wovon ich jemals geträumt habe, so was ich abkriege. Also es ist halt wirklich nochmal eine andere Kategorie. Und da fällt es mir wirklich schwer zu sagen, naja, oder zu glauben, naja, wenn die Gesellschaft ein bisschen besser ist, wenn wir mehr Sozialabgaben und so weiter haben, dann hört das auf. Ich glaube, das hört nicht auf. Es gab schon immer beispielsweise harte Nazis, harte Frauenfeinde in dieser Gesellschaft. Die wird es auch immer weitergeben. Und gerade im Kontext von MeToo, also dem Hashtag, unter dem ganz viele Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund oder die vielleicht auch anders aussehen, als wir uns so den Stereotype Deutsche vorstellen, über ihre Erfahrungen geschrieben haben. Was ich da an Hass oder Gehässigkeit gesehen hab, das ist halt purer Alltagsrassismus. Und die Leute sehen sich ja auch selbst nicht als Hater, sondern naja, das wird man einfach ja wohl noch mal sagen dürfen.
Aber siehst du das nicht auch sozusagen, dass es mega spannend wäre, wenn Facebook zum Beispiel mal damit rausrücken würde, wie sozusagen global in den unterschiedlichen Communities, in den unterschiedlichen Konflikten, in den unterschiedlichen sozialen Terrain sozusagen so dieses ganze Hassproblem aussieht. Also die haben ja die Daten. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass keiner die hätte. Ich weiß, dass es jetzt nur Vermutungen sind.
Ich würde schon unterschreiben, dass das spannend ist, sie anzugucken. Ich habe auch mal eine Zweifel, ob das sozusagen nur ein Problem zweiter Eben ist. Also ob das nur ist, was ist, was eine Grundlage hat und wenn man diese Grundlage ändert, dass es dann ganz weggeht. Aber das ist glaube ich eine Frage, ich würde gern Luca noch fragen, was er von der These oder Theorie hält.
Darf ich noch ganz kurz eine Sache reinfügen?
Aber ganz kurz.
Ja, also zum Beispiel was total schade ist, dass so klassische Institutionen die Rechtsradikalismus bekämpfen, wie die Amadeo-Antonio-Stiftung, dass die halt sozusagen seit den 90ern, also wurde diese Frage, was haben eigentlich Rassismen mit einem sozialen Stand zu tun? Die Frage, da gibt es keine Studien mehr zu. Und heute hätten wir die Möglichkeit diese Daten mal auszuwerten. Ob das in Zusammenhang gibt oder nicht.
Herr Hammer?
Ich glaube, dass ganz viel von dem Hass, den zumindest ich jetzt im Netz beobachte, auf falschen Annahmen auch passiert. Dort spielt sicherlich auch das Umfeld der Personen, die dann tatsächlich reagieren, eine gewisse Rolle. Aber ich glaube trotzdem auch, weil ich es bei Einzelpersonen manchmal verfolge, fälle es so weit, dass ich ein bisschen Verständnis davon habe, wer die Personen sind. Denen Personen geht es nicht unbedingt schlecht. Aber manchmal haben sie das Gefühl, dass es ihnen schlecht geht. Oder dass andere was besser haben, was mehr haben. Was sicherlich sehr menschlich ist. Das Gras auf der anderen Seite ist immer grüner. Aber von der Ungerechtigkeit im Alltag auf diese Gruppe ist das Problem zu schließen, ist sehr schwierig. Und ich glaube halt auch nicht nur, weil kleine Ungerechtigkeiten beseitigt werden, dass es insgesamt besser wird. Aber ich glaube sehr wohl, dass es, wenn es den Menschen insgesamt besser geht, weniger konkrete Feingruppen gibt.
Ja, was ich auch nochmal anmerken wollte, ich finde das total gut, sich bei Diskussionen über Hass im Netz auch sehr viel mit den Tätern auseinanderzusetzen. Ich würde mir allerdings wünschen, dass stärker auch die Opferperspektive zur Sprache kommt. Denn natürlich können wir uns damit auseinandersetzen. Na ja, geht es den Tätern jetzt schlecht? Könnte es den Tätern noch besser werden? Würden sie dann keine Täter mehr sein? Was ich mich allerdings auch frage, ist auch ganz konkret in meinem Umfeld, was kann ich tun, damit Menschen mit der Situation, wie sie jetzt nun gerade sind, die ich kurzfristig auch als eine Person nicht ändern kann, besser klarkommen können. Und wir können uns ja alle darauf einrichten, selbst wenn es jetzt irgendwie daran liegen würde, dass es uns ökonomisch schlecht geht. Wobei, würde ich zweifeln, in Deutschland geht es wirtschaftlich sehr gut. Und nicht alle Rechten sind geringverdiener. Das muss man halt auch so sehen. Nicht alle Frauenfeinde sind geringverdiener. Das ist bei weitem nicht so. Also wir können das nicht kurzfristig lösen. Was können wir denn machen, um den Leuten den Rücken zu stärken? Ich hab da viel auch mit Freundinnen, die in ähnlichen Situationen waren, wie ich drüber gesprochen. Und die sagen alle, wir wünschen uns mehr Unterstützung. Wie oft ist es dann so, dass man irgendwas auf Facebook sieht, da wird jemand angegangen und da denkt man sich, ich möchte nicht in die Schusslinie geraten. Bloß nicht hier irgendwie einmischen. Dabei wäre es ganz einfach, sich mal einzuklinken, einfach den Personen den Rücken zu stärken. Mir persönlich gibt es extrem viel, wenn ich Twitter oder Facebook aufmache. Dann sehe ich ganz kruden Mist. Dann hat aber jemand schon drunter kommentiert und gesagt, dass es Mist ist, dass ich das gar nicht mehr machen muss. Solche Dinge kann jeder von uns machen. Dafür braucht es kein Gesetz. Da braucht es den gesunden Menschenverstand zu. Und mehr Mut, Zivilcourage. Genauso wie ich in der Bahn einschreite, wenn ich sehe, jemand wird fremdenfeindlich belästigt, muss ich das eigentlich auch online machen. Das ist ganz, ganz klar. Wechseln geht da nicht.
Also im Prinzip ja. Und ich frage mich dann aber immer, das Problem an diesem sozialen Netzwerk ist ja momentan, das klang vorhin schon mal an, diese Interaktion. Also je mehr Interaktion etwas hat, desto höher wird es gerankt, desto sichtbarer wird es also. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich hingehe und nochmal auf etwas reagiere, was mistransportiert, helfe ich gleichzeitig dabei, es sichtbarer zu machen.
Das stimmt, das ist ein Problem. Aber trotzdem kann ich dir sagen, ich als Opfer, mir gibt es sehr viel, das zu lesen.
Ich wollte die Frage weiter stellen, auf welche Form man das machen soll. Also noch eine kleine Schleife. Wir haben in einer letzten Sendung über Mastodon geredet. Und Mastodon hat sich dagegen entschieden, so etwas wie Quotetweets zu machen. Auf Twitter geht es ja, ich kann einen Tweet, in meinen Tweet einbetten und dann dazu was schreiben. Das geht bei Mastodon nicht, sondern du kannst einen Tweet schreiben und dann steht da ein Link zu einem anderen Post. Das heißt, du musst extra klicken. Die Argumentation dahinter war, die Erregungs-Schleifen funktionieren vor allen Dingen auch darüber, dass ich etwas in meinen Tweet einbetten kann und sage, guck mal, wie scheiße das ist. Deswegen frage ich mich und ich habe das an mir selbst beobachtet und habe festgestellt, das stimmt. Also in dem Moment, wo ich das nicht mehr machen kann, tendiere ich dazu, weniger erregt zu schreiben. Und was ich jetzt fragen wollte ist, also ich habe gehört, ja, das ist hilfreich für die Opfer, wenn sich da geäußert wird, aber welche Art und Weise macht man das, um sozusagen gleichzeitig sichtbar machen zu verhindern? Also lieber öffentlich replying oder lieber DM oder egal, Hauptsache man sagt überhaupt irgendwas.
Nee, also DM finde ich persönlich, klar ist nett, aber gleichzeitig ist es halt auch so das Statement so, hey, ich äußere mich nicht öffentlich dazu. So ich flüsse das dir ins Ohr, dass ich eigentlich total zu dir stehe. Und das ist halt genauso, wenn man irgendwie in der Schule gemobbt wird und dann kommt jemand zu einem so, hey, nicht allen sagen, aber ich stehe voll hinter dir. Das ist dann halt ein bisschen traurig. Das ist sehr traurig. Nur wenn es jemand auch so schreibt, ich möchte das halt nicht irgendwie dem Bereich weitergehen, kann ich nachvollziehen, trotzdem wird es mich in den meisten Fällen mehr freuen, wenn jemand da halt direkt Positionen bezieht. Wobei für mich natürlich der Unterschied ist, was ist der Original Ausgangspost? Wenn irgendjemand, keine Ahnung, eine Photoshop-Nacktbild-Retouche von mir irgendwo gestellt hat und aus irgendwelchen rechtlichen Gründen kriege ich es nicht weg und ganz viele Leute kommentieren da drunter, würde ich vielleicht sagen, ja, schreib mir lieber eine DM. Oder eine Privatnachricht. Aber in den meisten Fällen geht es ja halt einfach nur, dass jemand irgendwas doof findet, was ich sage, wo ich denke, das finde ich jetzt nicht schlimm, wenn das hochgerankt wird. Obwohl es mich natürlich stört, wenn in der Aktion so Sachen hochrankt. Oder was ich aber auch mache, und da muss ich mich schuldig bekennen, ich binde manchmal auch Postings von anderen ein, weil das auch eine ganz typische Strategie ist, damit umzugehen. Natürlich kann ich in meinem stillen Camer-Line Leuten zeigen, guck mal, womit ich konfrontiert werde, weil ich mich zu diesem Thema äußere, aber ich mach das natürlich auch öffentlich. Also ich nehme auch einzelne Tweets, Screenshots, stelle die ins Netz oder binde die ein und sag mal, guck mal, geht es dir noch gut oder so. Dann weiß ich nicht, damit ich damit nicht alleine bin. Und ich finde es auch okay, wenn andere Leute das machen.
Wie gesagt, unsicher.
Vielleicht würde ich das Thema noch auf eine andere Ebene heben, sozusagen in der Politik, wenn man wirklich politische Sachen sagt, sowohl ich bei Netzpolitik, aber auch andere Politiker, die ich kenne. Es ist oft das Problem, dass die kritischen Kommentare oft in den Kommentarspaten unter den Blogs eingehen und das Lob per E-Mail oder per Telefon. Natürlich freuen wir uns total über das Lob und per E-Mail und per Telefon. Aber es ist sozusagen für die Meinungsbildung in den Gruppen, wo wir uns bewegen, super schwierig, weil wir sozusagen unseren Kollegen erklären müssen, warum wir von außen nur Wind kriegen, obwohl wir in sozusagen eigentlich auch noch andere, also die Meinung, also eigentlich wäre es gut. Ich glaube, dass sich halt sozusagen unglaublich viele normale Leute nicht in die Kommentarspalten verirren, weil da halt schon mal so viel Scheiß läuft. Obwohl die, wenn sie gut läuft, unglaublich interessant sind, weil man kann durch die Kommentarspalten ganz viel diskutieren, was man nicht im Artikel diskutieren kann. Also ich finde die sehr, sehr spannend, aber da verirren sich halt wenig Menschen zu tun, Menschen hin, die da nicht hin müssen, weil einfach aus Zeitgründen und so, weil sie verrufen sind. Aber es wäre manchmal hilfreich, wenn die Leute auch mal unten drunter gucken würden. Ich gucke manchmal Tweets unten drunter, wenn ich weiß, das ist jetzt hier auf jeden Fall wirklich politisch. Und dann mische ich mich auch mal ein, wenn ich denjenigen mag und da nur Gegenwind kommt. Aber der Gegenwind öffentlich ist wesentlich härter.
Aber das ist auch schon wieder ein bisschen deprimierend. Also an der öffentlichen Wand ist es hart. Deswegen traut das dann selbstverfahren das System auch.
Ja, ich finde das ist unterschiedlich von Medium zu Medium und von Forum, Kommentarspalte zu Kommentarspalte. Das ist halt wie so ein Teich. Also wenn ein Teich einmal so zu viele Eigenheit und Blätter ist, der euphotrophiert, dann stirbt alles darin. Da bleiben halt irgendwann nur so kleine Blaualgen drin. Ja, so eine Monokultur. Genauso kann man sich einen Online-Forum vorstellen, wenn man nicht ordentlich moderiert. Also irgendwann geht dann alles Leben raus. Es bleiben dann halt nur noch einige wenige, die dann halt den Ton angeben. Und auch alle niedermachen, die gegenreden. Und deshalb ist es ganz wichtig, immer zu gucken, dass man moderiert. Also ich bin sehr für die Pressefreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit. Aber ich bin gleichzeitig auch ein Mensch, der sagt, meine Kommentarspalte in meinem Blog, da bestimme ich. Also ich gehe ja auch nicht zu jemandem anderen. Und auf eine Party und kacke ihm auf den Tisch. Und genauso möchte ich in meinen Kommentarspalten schalte ich nichts frei, wo irgendwie links zu rechten Blogs gehen. Oder wo jemand halt irgendwie mir droht. Warum soll ich einen Kommentar mit Drohungen über mich freischalten? Und genauso finde ich das auch okay, wenn Nachrichtenseiten moderieren. Und ich finde es auch krass, dass es mittlerweile immer mehr Nachrichtenseiten gibt, die sagen, ich komme nicht hinterher mit der Moderation, oder wir kommen nicht hinterher. Es gibt einfach keine Kommentarfunktion mehr. Aber es ist auch aus dem Grund, und ich finde es auch konsequent zu sagen, wenn man nicht genug Kapazitäten hat, um das zu moderieren, dann machen wir es nicht. Das finde ich absolut richtig. Weil es beeinflusst Menschen auch, wenn ich einen Artikel lese und darunter einfach nur aus Interesse gucke, was war das Meistgelesende, Meistgeleigte. Und wenn das wirklich volksverhetzendes Kram ist oder wirklich verletzendes Zeug, beleidigendes, auch inhaltlich gar nicht mehrwertig, dann verschiebt das die Debatte in eine ganz, ganz grüne Richtung, wo ich mich dann natürlich nicht wohl genug fühle, um zu denken, ach ja, da kommentiere ich jetzt mal.
Das finde ich auch ganz interessant, weil man oft hat so fast schon, ich nehme es als Reflex wahr, wenn ein Medium sagt, wir stellen Kommentare ganz ein, oder sagt, nur bei ausgewählten Artikeln stellen wir eine Kommentarmöglichkeit zur Verfügung. Das ist so eine Reflexreaktion. Immer so, ja, aber das ist doch gerade das Geile am Internet, das alle immer alles überall sagen wollen. Wo ich auch so denke, naja, aber vielleicht ist es tatsächlich besser, wenn man sozusagen gezielt Diskussionen zulässt und die dann aber auch gut durchmoderiert.
Ich denke mir halt, ich möchte meine Leser halt auch schützen irgendwo. Ich möchte meine Leser davor schützen, dass sie persönlich angegangen werden, dass sie bedroht werden, beleidigt werden. Ich möchte in meinem Block einen Raum schaffen, wo Menschen sich nicht schämen müssen für ihre Geschlecht, für ihre Sexualität, für ihre Herkunft, was auch immer. Und das bedeutet für mich eben auch, wenn ich über die AfD schreibe, bei Themen, wo einfach dann auch mal auf den Knopfdruck plötzlich 20 Posts auf einmal kommen, dass ich die vorher freischalte. Das ist dann doof für die Diskussion, weil ich komme da nicht hinterher. Aber ansonsten hätte ich halt wirklich grues Zeug da stehen, wo sich niemand mehr wohlfühlen würde, zu sagen, ich kommentiere hier.
Also öffentlich loben, auch mal durch moderieren. Luca Hammer, hast du noch ein Rat oder Mitschlag für uns? Alles klar. Dann bedanke ich mich bei euch, dass ihr heute hier wart und wir über dieses... Doch, ja.
Bitte was?
Ich bekomme eine... Was? Mir wird gerade bedeutet, dass ich das machen soll, was ich eh gerade machen wollte. Aber vorher wollte ich mich noch bedanken bei Julia Krüger, Luca Hammer und Katharina Nocun, die hier waren und mit mir über dieses echt schwierige Thema geredet haben. Es gibt Sendungen, wo ich denke, die Musik, man muss das, aber ich war echt froh, zwischendurch ein bisschen Luft holen zu können. War schon ganz gut. Danke, dass ihr das mit mir durchgemacht habt. Und genau, wie jetzt zum Ende der Sendung ist, ich gehört noch zwei Hinweise. Das eine ist, vom 17. bis 18. November gibt es die Konferenz Bits und Bäume für Digitalisierung und Nachhaltigkeit. Also vielleicht ist da auch ein Ort, wo man die Welt ein bisschen besser machen kann, die im Endeffekt dazu führt, dass wir weniger Hass haben. Da geht es, wie gesagt, um die Bereiche Digitalisierung und Ökologie zusammengehen. Und das andere, dass sich wahrscheinlich alle fragen, die irgendwas mit Chaos zu hören ist, gibt es einen Kongress? Ja. Wo ist der in Leipzig? Wann gibt es Tickets? Tickets gibt es im Vorverkauf. Am 8. November um 12, am 11. November um 14 Uhr und am 21. November um 21 Uhr. Dann gibt es also auf der Webseite dann die Ticketverkaufstermine. Fahrt hin, habt Spaß, hinterlasst uns Kommentare, lobt uns öffentlich, wenn ihr es habt. Ansonsten hab ich nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Marcus Richter, seid lieb, nett und respektvoll zueinander und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Und don't forget I'm in your extended network.